you don't try to sleep
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
a global digital business transformation
partner helping organizations improve
lives through digital elevating
experiences optimizing data and
Reinventing products all to create a
better tomorrow for who matters most
everyone
publishes Sapient
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
what if digital could help your
organization change the world for the
better better Technologies better
experiences better tomorrows we're
publicist Sapient a global digital
business transformation partner helping
organizations improve lives through
digital elevating experiences optimizing
data and Reinventing products all to
create a better tomorrow for who matters
most everyone
[Music]
foreign
instructions
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
trying to stay
dry
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
good morning good afternoon and good
evening to everyone tuned in today
welcome to the pre-event virtual Meetup
of jsconf India sponsored by publisher
Sapient and epam I am pradeep bhosely
and I'm going to be your host for today
whether you're sipping your late night
Coffee in San Francisco or having your
morning tea in Amsterdam JS const is
thrilled to be Bridging the time zones
and geographical barriers to bring
together an electric group of JavaScript
enthusiasts
JavaScript was introduced in the mid 90s
and since then JavaScript has been the
main character of a lot of big companies
products controversies and memes I'm
pretty sure everyone has been has seen
these memes at some point of their life
before introducing our Excel excellent
speakers I want to thank our sponsors
for having us make Jace con India a
reality
public recipient is our diversity
sponsor a global Giant in the digital
transformation and Consulting domain we
also have epam story block deep Graham
as our glorious gold sponsors a big
shout out to a good sponsor epam India
thank you for supporting the vision of
JavaScript conference folks if you want
to be a part of the awesome team at epam
India check out their open opportunities
storyblock is a Content management
system that empowers developers and
marketers to create better content
experiences across any digital channel
and deep Graham is a foundational AI
company on a mission to understand human
language they give developers the access
to the most advanced speech a speech AI
transcriptions with just an API call we
are now going to move towards the talks
for today first up we have Daniel
Alfonso with us Daniel is a published
author and an international speaker
Daniel is also a developer advocate for
OLX and an odd zero Ambassador next we
have the community's favorite Phil Nash
Phil is a developer evangelist you can
find Phil code almost everywhere in
front of a live audience in person on
Twitter in his blogs and many more
places
we also have Rajesh Kumar joining us
today Rajesh is a front-end engineer
mentor and speaker he loves talking
about the web and exploring new
technologies our next speaker is a
15-time global hackathon winner
currently interning at push protocol
satyam Singh is a developer and a Serial
Builder foreign
systems hanuma is a Solutions architect
who is proficient in several programming
languages including JavaScript c-sharp
and Java we have we also have Josh
Goldberg giving us a final talk Josh is
an author speaker open source maintainer
on projects in the typescript ecosystem
so let us finally start with today's
first talk buy a birthday boy Daniel
Alfonso hey Daniel happy birthday how
are you today yeah well thank you so
much for having me it's a pleasure to be
here on this day as well makes it even
more special for me so thank you for
having me
the stage is all yours Daniel please go
ahead with your talks yeah I'll be
sharing my screen
Okay so
okay so let me see
okay so you should be seeing you should
be seeing my slides now
um let me just put my stuff ready okay
so
thank you so much for having me today
it's a pleasure to be here speaking to
all of you in this pre-event today
unfortunately I know I won't be able to
join you all on on June 2nd but still
I'm still pray
um
um full week super excited for the event
and hope that you all have fun uh there
and I'll still have fun today so today
I'm here to talk to you to you all about
State and state is the art of the heart
of your applications really I challenge
you to try to build any application
nowadays without State well you could
for a bit but then probably you would
end up like probably starting ripping
your ears and being in panic because
well you'd think why would you why would
you do that because like I said state is
the art of the application it's the
thing that moves everything inside of it
and this is why State Management became
so essential to our applications
nowadays really just look at all the
State Management Solutions that exist to
manage it and these are just some
examples of the hundreds or thousands of
ones that exist
now I would like to ask you a question
and something to reflect on which is
what is State what's really State
because
state is often defined as a mutable data
source that can be used to store data
relevant to your application and this
data can change over the time and is
used to determine all your component
renders in the reactical system there
are kind of several ways to handle State
natively throughout this presentation
just an FYI I'll be showing a bunch of
examples mostly in react but don't worry
about it because the concepts some of
the concepts will be transmissible when
we'll work on other Frameworks and
libraries so
um just a heads up and like I said in
the reactical system there are several
ways to handle State natively we have
used States and we have use reducer and
they work pretty well to manage com
stating your own components but then
there was a time that we kind of started
needing to share State between multiple
components and this is when context hit
the frame
and yeah it worked pretty well but
thanks to the way that context works and
the way that we were not prepared to use
it I would say we ended up having
unrelated logic group together in pretty
much the same context and this kind of
led to a huge amount of unnecessary
re-renders in our components and our
applications and this is once again when
we started resorting to external
libraries
heck some of us even kind of skipped the
native solution and went straight to
Redux because that's what seemed
everyone else was using
and I think that there are a million
ways of how we can manage our shared
States really try to get a bunch of
react developers together in the same
room and I guarantee you that probably
after the rap servers and server
components and a bunch of other
discussions the discussion will
eventually turn into which state
management Library it's it's better
and at the end of the day it kind of
just it's relates to a personal
preference it relates to something that
it depends on you it depends on your
team it depends on your context because
each one of these Solutions have
different ways to be used but
at the end of the day they all exist to
do something which is give us a way to
manage our shared States and this is the
state that is shared by all of our
components and often this state is known
as Global State now there's an issue
with global state which is kind of what
prompted me to do this presentation
because Global state is a container
and as a container it means that it can
it can encapsulate several types of
state and each one of them has different
needs and challenges and each one of
these different things and challenges
should be handled by their own specific
tools and this is the part that I want
you to turn your attention now
because I would really like to stop
discussing which state management
libraries better for a while and look at
our code because like I said Global
state is a container and this container
can be split into client and server
State and because we have not been
paying attention to the right discussion
so far we might be misusing our tools
and wasting our own time
so welcome to my presentation called you
don't know server state yet I'm Daniel
Alphonse I'm the person on the left on
this photo if you didn't recognize me
the other one is my junior developer
who's up there always supporting me and
acting as my rubber deck I'm a developer
Advocate at OLX I'm an I get IO
instructor out zero Ambassador and the
author of The just released book State
Management with react query which might
have something related with stuff that
we'll be seeing in this presentation
speaking of which giveaway time
throughout this presentation
um you can all go to this QR code that
you see here feel free to scan it add
your name and your email and after the
tokens I'll be doing a giveaway of my
digital copy of my book to five lucky
people then I'll be announcing the
winners on my on my Twitter profile
which you can see here at Daniel phones
so I'll give you just a couple more
seconds so that you can scan it
and then we'll continue with the
presentation
okay also the car code a bit later so
don't worry if you didn't get that got
time to do it now
so
let's focus on splitting States because
this is what what we need to do like I
said Global state is a container and
this container encapsulates client State
and server State and what many of us
have been doing so far has been entering
Global State as one and kind of
forgetting about each one of these
individually because when we have Redux
Zoo stand whatever in our applications
many of us kind of just have everything
inside of it and don't know how to
handle it differently because both coins
State and server State have different
challenges and they represent different
things now some of you might be
wondering okay but what's client State
what's server State well
let's start with the client State just
so we can wrap it whereas this part up
client state is a state that is local so
it means that it only exists in your
application right now therefore it means
that it's probably synchronous so it
means that you don't need to wait to get
it probably you access it by
accessing a variable or covering a
getter in your code so you don't have to
wait to get this data therefore it's
also might be temporary so what this
means is probably if you refresh your
page this state is going to end up
disappearing and this is kind State this
is Matt's picture and an example that
might be so imagine that we have a team
changer or another application uh this
might be an example of client state
now there's this state is handled in a
different way that's than server State
because server state has different
challenges and represents completely
different thing because server state is
actually persisted remotely so this is a
state that exists Somewhere over the
internet somewhere out there there's a
database where we have our data and this
is where this state exists so if this
state is persisted remotely then
probably it means that it's a
synchronous so we probably need to wait
to get this data probably we're going to
have to do a data fetch request or ask
for this data somewhere on the internet
and considering all of these things then
there's probably no guarantee that this
state is up to date so what I mean by
this is if it exists on the internet you
get the data for you but there's no
guarantee that somewhere
throughout this world someone else
hasn't done any changes on this data
after you got it so there's no
guarantees that the state that you're
showing to your user right now is
actually up to date
and this kind of
um gets a bunch of other challenges that
we have to deal when dealing with this
type of State because the first thing
that probably Pops to mind when dealing
with data fetching and all these types
of things is caching so we don't want to
be always doing the same request to get
the data or we want to make sure that we
kind of reduce the amount of times that
we get the data ask for the data on our
client side just to save them a bit of
give them a bit of a break
then speaking of these parts there's
also the duping request so there's going
to be there's going to be eventual
scenarios that this data set might be
needed for instance Intrigue components
of your code so indeed when we are
deduping requests
or if the duping request didn't exist
what would happen is each one of these
three components would do their own
individual request through the internet
to get this data when we are deduping
requests one of only one of these
requests is going to end up being going
out there and once it gets back the data
it feeds it to all these three sources
and therefore avoiding having duplicated
requests
one example one thing that I mentioned
previously is that there's no guarantees
that this data is updated so we have to
make sure that there's a way that we can
manage updated data being by
invalidating uh data by menuing
refreshing by doing automatic refreshing
refetching and a bunch of other stuff
then we get some patterns that often are
related with this type of
um challenge which is which is
optimistic updates so for those of you
who are not aware with what of this
optimistical plates is I want you to
think it of this wave so imagine that
you have a UI where you're showing data
to your user and somewhere you're going
your user is going to want to update
this data so an optimistic apparatus
whilst the data update is going out
there into the internet to be committed
to a server you as um as a developer in
this scenario your page is already
showing the updated data to your user
even before the data is updated to the
server so pretty much we are up to
holistic that this data is going to be
committed it's going to be end up in a
server so we can already give a better
user experience to your app users by
giving them a view of how their app will
look after they did an update and this
is a pattern that's usually very tricky
to manage and then we have about a bunch
of other challenges like managing um
paginated data implementing infinite
scrolling and doing device evolving
and these are just some of the
challenges that server State brings into
your application and
now
for those of you that are only using
Redux to manage all the state and have a
bunch of Fetch and axial stuff out there
think about having to implement stuff to
manage all of these things really think
about that for a bit you have to build a
code for caching the premium request
imaginating update data optimistic
updates supporting paginated data
infinite scrolling waste loading really
think about the amount the amount of
months that would take you to do this
and the amount of code lines that will
take you
yeah it's probably my reaction too I
just want to throw my laptop away and
see okay I don't want to do this anymore
because probably you ended up like a
pull request with 20 or 30 000 changes
just to implement all of these things
and because
is the thing we need to like I said
Twitter coin set in our server State and
have it being managed differently whilst
we can have Redux mobex Zoo stand and
pretty much other State Management
solution to manage your client State we
need something different to end our
server State we want to avoid having to
maintain and add code all these things
by ourselves because remember every time
we have to implement Something New by
yourself you're going to have a wasting
more of your development time taking
more time to have your product delivered
and shipped to your users and be
responsible for fixing all the bugs and
stuff that came from it and with server
State it's so so so easy to commit these
issues and this is why we need to split
them everything new to manage server
state and this is where 10 stack query
comes into the mix
now 10 stack query or as it was called
before V4 react query is a protocol
agnostic collection of hooks for
fetching caching and updating the server
State now
I introduced the test and stack query
now I mentioned react query because like
I said it was this project started
started as react query around three or
four years ago and then since it's
version 4 it was merged into the set of
libraries called 10 stack which is
um a collection of software built by the
creator of react query Tanner Winsley
therefore 10 stack and since
um recent years now it works on reacts
on solid on view and on svelte so
therefore if you hear now the name 10
stack query it's probably referring to
which one of these sets if you hear
someone say react query don't worry it's
still a acceptable answer because I
asked Tanner pretty much when if someone
says react query what you have to think
is okay I'm talking about the react
adapter of 10 stack queries so there's
nothing wrong with still saying react
query throughout this presentation I'll
probably mix the terms but all the
examples that you'll be seeing are for
react query but they still work in solid
in View and svelte you just need to do
some small changes because hopefully
I'll teach you the metal models and the
fundamentals that you need to understand
this and how they handles your server
state
so there are only two fundamentals that
you need to grasp to handle 10 step
query the first one are queries and the
second one that are multiplications so
the quiz I want you to think as the
thing that is responsible for going out
there on the internet and getting your
data so queries are responsible for
fetching your data Somewhere over the
internet
then pretty much that's it think of
queries as Getters now
on the other side if you can get your
data you're probably going to want to
update it or create it or delete it and
this is where mutations come into the
mix whilst queries are there to get your
data mutations are there to change it
create it or delete it so when whenever
you do mutation limitation goes out
there over the Internet finds your
servant says hey I would like you to
create this data I would like you to
delete this data and so on and yeah
that's pretty much the fundamentals that
you need to understand 10 stack create
so now let's get a vintage to some react
query examples and see how these things
translate into code
so starting with queries there's a hook
called use Query in react and in view if
I'm not wrong and in solid and then
svelt it's called create query but the
process is pretty much the same each one
of these instances requires two things a
query key and a query function and
starting with the writer one which is
the query function the query function is
a function that's protocol agnostic that
as long as it returns a promise it
should work and it's responsible for
getting your data and what I mean by
this it means that as long as you use
um as something that returns a promise
it means that you can use graphql means
that you can use rest Heck if you want
you can even use soap if people still
use soap out there as long as it's a
function that returns a promise it will
work and this is the exciting thing
about react query 10 stackery whatever
is that if you have a shared code base
or code base that kind of ends up using
built you can use it
and yeah going back query function is
responsible to be the function to get
this data on the other side you have
your query key the query key is
responsible for identifying the data
that is returned from your query
function in the cache so what this means
is that automatically every time you do
a data Fetch and a data request this
data is going to be cached automatically
and this is actually something that
react query brings out of the box and
this was probably one of the things that
first caught my eye when thinking about
this because I remember that
when we started working with the 10
stack we react query at the time we were
trying to implement caching by ourselves
and after having a bunch of discussions
a bunch of patterns and we've when we
found this Library it was pretty much
okay well this is caching out
automatically I don't have to worry
about it really just think about
the power of with four lines of code you
have caching automatic right amazing
and yeah these are two things that are
mandatory you always have to have our
query key and your query function just
something to be aware quickies need to
be erased now you might be thinking some
of you that probably are using already
react query or 10 stack creating your
code
wait but I have it and it's not a race
well since 4 they become
strongly recommended to be a race and
after and of the version that currently
is Alpha in Alpha which is V5 it's going
to be mandatory so if you don't have
them as a race then I have a suggestion
add a ticket to start doing the
migration
and I would like you to treat uh query
Keys as a dependence here right what I
mean by this is you should have all the
variables in it that your query depends
upon because if we look at the second
example that we have here as you can see
we are passing a string user which is a
query identifier like I like to call it
and then we have page and filters and on
this line of codex you can see here it's
pretty much the way that we Implement
Implement pagination with react query
because page and filters are
dependencies of my query and then I need
them to be able to get my data because I
probably want to get the page one or
page two or whatever
um so my recommendation for you is treat
dependence queries as dependencies
arrays array because they are the things
that I better identify your query in the
query cache
an example of a query function I know
this code is very big but I'll wrap it
up very quickly so in the beginning in
the first 10 ones we have our graphql
query and then on the other ones we have
our query function which is called it's
called Fetch is gql and it's pretty much
responsible for doing or query so this
is the graphql code for you executing a
query and then all we have to do is pass
our fetch gql function to our use Query
hook and whenever this hook mounts or
whenever this Hook is called by a
component then this data is going to be
fetched automatically and cached in this
scenario underneath posts
and yeah that's pretty much all that you
need to know about
um quiz just one extra thing and just to
also show you an example of this working
with rest
here we have an example where we have
our query key which is an array on the
first element we have an object with our
query identifier and our API name and
this is a pattern that I like to apply
because it fully shows why we should
treat this stuff as our dependencies of
our query because if we look at the code
right now on line one you can see that
we have access to our query key
this means that
um you can buy something that's the
query function has which is called the
query function context you can have
access to your query key and because of
that as you can see on line two we have
access to our API name and because we
have access to our API name which we can
see here online node two we can
customize the endpoint that we are going
to be getting our data from and
therefore we can do data fetch data
request to different endpoints at
different times
name
that's it that's pretty much all that
you need to know to have out of the box
right now
um caching and data fetching without
many lines of code before we go to
mutations I just want to give you
um two options that you should be aware
on I just want to try to create the dots
in some people's minds with when talking
about react query so the first one is
cache time which after V5 is going to be
renamed as GC time and then we have
still time so these are two different
options that you can pass along your
query function and your query key to
customize our react query takes care of
your data
so for the cache time there's one
consideration because many times and
this is why it's been has been renamed
in V5 many times people assume that
cache time is the amount of time that
your data will be cached which is not
right
partially because cash time is the
duration in milliseconds until an
inactive query data is garbage collected
so what does this mean it means that
whenever you set a cache time for
instance of 60 milliseconds what will
happen is after that query is no longer
being used so imagine that the hook the
component that's using it
is no longer rendering that could become
inactive because not no one else is
using it so only after this time that
the cache time will kick in and tell
react query hey look after one minute
this data is going to be garbage
collected and that's pretty much the
entire model that you need to know for
Cash Time and this is why it has been
renamed GC time in V5 therefore
um mentioning garbage collect garbage
collection time
and yeah that's pretty much all I do
regarding this option regarding still
time it's a different thing so still
time is the duration until a query data
is no longer considered fresh and this
all goes back to the managing outdated
data that I mentioned so after you do um
data fetch request like I said from the
second that you get that data it might
no longer be fresh so still time is
there so that allows you to tell react
query hey look during this time during
this time that I'm telling you after you
get this data this data is going to be
considered fresh so imagine that you
have a 60 milliseconds still time it
means that after you just got that data
from the internet and brought it back to
your cache it will be considered fresh
during 16 milliseconds after that part
is going to be considered still
and yeah just some options that you some
option of the many many others that you
can use to customize your use Query hook
going into the mutations part
that's just one example because that's
pretty much kind of the gist of
mutations on the beginning first three
lines we have a create user function and
this will be our mutation function the
function that's responsible for doing
our mutation in this scenario we are
doing pretty much a post request to our
name API with our user data then we have
our use mutation hook which on this
scenario only needs the mutation
function that it's not required to have
a mutation key even though you can use
it to do a couple of fun things in V5
even though right now it's still not I
haven't found the issue to
um a scenario where it can be useful but
in V5 it's going to allow you to do some
very cool things especially regarding
optimistic updates but this is me Rambo
in sorry with the structure the mutate
function and this function can be called
whenever we want to do a mutation for
instance when a query executes
automatically mutations only execute
whenever you want it
so now I'll drag you to show show you
some code and a small example but before
like I said the beginning just a
reminder that we're still going to have
a giveaway for five copies of my book
State Management we react query and
we'll see a bunch of stuff that
all the things that we've seen here and
many many others like integrating react
query to remix next.js a bunch of
testing patterns hopefully
um I have time to show you some examples
but yeah you can you can still apply and
after the the talk I'll be doing the
giveaway and then I'll sing the winners
on my Twitter account
okay so let me find the code just stop
sharing for a bit here so here we have
this application that you should be
seeing let me just zoom in because it's
very very small
so this is a note-taking application
where you can only add notes you cannot
remove them and even pretty much if I
refresh you can see that there was a
fetching data indicator we have an input
box where you can add
a row two note when you add it the data
was sent there was an update and now the
data is being shown to the user so how
does this work with react query let's
see the code
okay so here we have um our demo
component let me just take this out of
the way so you don't need to work out
here so this component is doing a couple
of things before we go into the the code
part let's just see what we are
rendering what we already saw so here we
have a div with that whenever we are
fetching is showing the it's fetching
diapers after we got our data we can
just show the our data that we need and
this is pretty much the part of this
Frame the data of the notes and then we
have a form where we have an input that
after this input is submitted whenever
we click on submit we're going to want
to send the data that we have here so
pretty much what we have here is a use
State just to keep track of our nodes
and we'll see the rest of the code so
coming back up here we have a cost
called apia which pretty much is the
route that we want to use to submit our
data to and to fetch it
and then here we have a fetch data which
is going to be our query function that
like you saw previously we have access
to our query key in our query query
function context and from it we get our
API name which is going to be customized
so that we can fetch our data from
whatever route we want and the reason
why I like this pattern is it kind of
just doesn't tie your your
um
your endpoint your function with a
specific endpoint in this scenario you
can just get as long as it you know it's
going to be going to this end point you
can customize the route that you want in
your query key so this is one of the
real cool things while I like this
pattern
and then we have a create note function
and this function is pretty much a
function that is going to receive a note
and then it's going to trigger a post to
an endpoint just to send the notes there
going into our code here we have
something let me just hide this first
you know we have a use Query function
which has a query key query identified
API and API name a so this means that
whenever we call this fetch data query
function like I said we're going to send
that this const and this as this API
name
so this means when this component
renders we're going to be triggering a
data fetch request to that endpoint to
get our data so once we get our data
react query caches it makes it
accessible over the data and then we can
show it there's also this is fetching
indicator which is a fetch status which
allows you to have access to
the current status of your query
function so whilst your query function
is fetching some data this is fetching
will be is true it's true so you can
have some State indicators
now working on a third mutation it's
pretty much a mutation function create
note and annotate function which will
receive a note and
pretty much trigger your post to change
your data
and that's pretty much it but I don't
know if you saw something in the in the
code which is look at here whilst I add
a new note
foot fetching like it so that was a
loading indicator for a while there
because
and this is kind of the managing updated
data section What's Happening Here is
I'm telling react query that after I do
a mutation I want you to update my query
data so how does this works I have
access to something which is called the
query client and so the query client is
something that we need to create
and pass it to a provider whenever and
wrap our code that wants to use react
query in our application so I would like
you to think as the quick client as the
react query heart it's where the cache
sits and a bunch of other details that
you can use and because I have access to
my query clients I can do something in
here so I'm customizing my use mutation
hook to tell him hey look on success I
want you to do something in this
scenario what I want you to do is go
into your query client go into your
cache and invalidate the query that has
the following query key and as you can
see as am I writing this it highlights
the query up there so what's happening
here is that I'm telling react query
after the mutation I want you to update
this data and refetch the data
automatically and yeah that's pretty
much the magic that it does it manages
um outdated data automatically for you
which is super cool as you can see just
on this example we see data fetching
mutations caching out managing outdated
data
um and probably something I'm forgetting
as well because there's a lot of
patterns and things that you can use
with react query if you check this
repository which I can share after you
this is the repository of the code of
the book that I'm giving away it has a
bunch of these patterns it as you can
see you can build infinite queries with
um the infinity query hook you can build
multiple queries you can there's several
ways of doing mutations optimistic
updates paginated queries and something
very cool as well it works with next it
works with remix there's a bunch of
patterns that you can apply out there so
for the sake of time and now as I'm just
wrapping up let's let's go back to the
slides
and as you can see there are a bunch of
stuff that you can do with react query
and just from some of these examples
we saw
well let me see the quicker's not worthy
okay it's back we saw caching we saw the
looping we didn't see the looping
requests but it kind of just works
because huge query takes care of it we
didn't see paginated later but I showed
that there was an example there we saw
managing updated data you saw that there
exists a way to do optimistic updates
there's a way to do infinite scrolling
there's a way to the amazing world and
there's a way to do stuff that we didn't
even talk about like scroll restoration
offline support and after prefetching
and many others and that's the thing
with server State server status so so so
many challenges and when you start
confusing it with clients they can try
to take care of all these instances of
your code fact they are the same things
you're soon going to find yourself
and a bunch of issues so think about it
look at your code look at your crime
State look at your server State see how
you should split them and give them
stack query
a shot
like I said you um it kind of just
changes the way that I understate and
especially server state
so hopefully by now you know a bit more
about server State
um thank you so much for having me it
has been a pleasure to be here on this
special day especially for me you can
scan this character already has a bunch
of my common links in my Twitter account
my LinkedIn page the Amazon page for my
book and like I said I'll be announcing
the giveaway winners at my Twitter
profile at Daniel phones um in a bit so
once again thank you so much for being
here for watching this talk and for
having me and I wish you all the rest of
an amazing day
thank you so much Janel it was an
amazing talk uh next up we have Phil
Nash
and
I'm excited to have him on on board
today hi Phil how are you I'm good thank
you how are you doing
uh do you have any sort of a pre-talk
routine that you follow to give you an
example about what I mean by a pre-talk
routine is a very famous cricketer in
India named Zahir Khan before playing
his match he will always carry a yellow
color handkerchief Because he believes
that whenever he carries that
handkerchief he's gonna definitely take
some wickets and gonna Help win the
match so similarly do you have any
routine
ah no routine as such I think I mostly
just pace around one worrying about uh
the next words I'm gonna say
uh and then and then you get on stage or
you get on camera and you have to stop
the pacing and and just be ready that's
uh that's about all I do nothing uh
nothing I think about I'm afraid
well
I think then it's all your charm food
that's working
for your dog ahead all right thank you
so much
all right what's up everybody I've got
my slides on screen that's excellent it
is great to be here at this online
version uh pre-jsconf India Meetup it's
great to be here with you I do want to
shout out that I have uh the chat window
if you're watching on on YouTube over to
my right hand side here so if you want
to give us a shout out there uh I can
see you and I love having kind of an
interactive talk uh if we can ever
manage that so uh hello
of course there's a bit of delay on it
so if I don't see the message straight
away don't worry about it today we're
going to talk a little bit about
passwords um but first of all my name is
Phil Nash I am a developer Advocate at a
company called sonar so now if you don't
know uh does static analysis tools for
your applications to help you write
clean code clean maintainable and secure
code uh we have Sona Cube and Sona Cloud
which are the the either self-hosted or
Cloud hosted version of the analysis
service and sonalint which is a free in
ide linter that you can use to um uh to
to check your code as you're writing it
I can see people shouting uh people uh
people shouting on the chat now hello to
everyone it's great to see you all
um
about a little bit about me though yeah
I'm I'm uh here in Melbourne Australia
so it is it's now gone eight o'clock at
night it's 20 past eight at night uh I
am uh I am almost done for the day but
very happy to be a part of this uh if
you ever want to find me online you can
find me at Phil Nash effectively
everywhere that's on Twitter
thornashmasterdon.social if you're on
there or just drop me online on LinkedIn
uh or hit my website uh I have it's my
favorite domain in the world because
it's just my name and I'm very happy
about that
um cool so let's get on with this talk
uh passwords you want to talk about
passwords so that we can get rid of them
right uh I hope you agree with me that
passwords are terrible uh just just a
horrible thing that we had to invent at
one point because we had nothing better
but we are moving to a world in which
that is no longer the case uh we are
going to get rid of them
and so uh let me tell you why they're
terrible I'm going to start with some
statistics first uh This was um some
some answers from a survey that Google
did back at the in December 2018 uh
where they asked a few questions about
passwords but one of them was how often
do you reuse passwords uh now again you
can shout out in the chat if you which
which of these things you fall into is
it some of the time all the time or
never
um in blue there 52 of people said that
they reuse passwords some of the time
and that's a bad start because any kind
of reuse of passwords makes your uh
makes your account you know a uh
potentially
um
uh at risk uh not quite as at risk as if
you're the 13 of people who reuse their
passwords all of the time I like those
people they're they're very bold and
they're just I have one password a
single single thing I need to remember
and that's all I need in order to log
into every single one of my accounts or
you know maybe they only have like three
accounts on the internet I don't I don't
know
the good section on this and I hope that
that's uh where you lie as well is the
people who say they never reuse their
passwords they always use a unique
password uh for every application and I
just saw uh Fusion chats they never use
never remember yeah absolutely
um password managers are in fact the uh
the answer here probably right
um but never reusing passwords is great
uh that's saying all of the time don't
do it
um that same survey actually asked the
question do you use a password manager
and the answer to that 24 of people said
that they use a password manager and uh
and that that got me thinking uh a
little bit worried honestly about that
that 35 of people that say that they
they never reuse passwords because
that's so like a 11 Gap there
of of people with either an incredible
memory who have a unique password for
every application they just remember
them all or I don't know like a bunch of
sticky notes across their monitor it
could have been it could have been
anything
um
so uh I have to say uh for anybody
people any of you saying all of the time
get yourself a password manager this is
uh this is the way to to fix this for
yourself right now go use a password
manager to make unique passwords for
every application
um
be part of this 24 in fact let's bring
this 24 up now
um
speaking of passwords and passwords
people reuse I hope uh it's a nordpass
which is a which is a password manager
uh uh release date top 10 passwords of
2022 at the end of the end of last year
uh and it has all my favorite passwords
on there none of which are actually my
password at home of course uh it's good
to see the password password uh heading
in at number one uh absolutely uh well
done to password there and one two three
four five six which is a hot favorite
normally uh in at number two uh I hope
again uh none of you are seeing your
passwords uh as part of this list and if
you are you should probably stop
listening to me now and go change it
um
so our users are either reusing their
passwords some or all of the time
um some of them aren't
um some of them using password managers
some of them are using the worst
passwords in the world but some people
you know may pick good passwords uh and
then it turns out that uh websites and
applications around the world uh just
leak those passwords onto the internet
um there is a service out there called
have ibimponed.com that's run by uh Troy
hunt he's a also in Australia actually
um which has gathered uh all of the uh
or as many password breaches and data
breaches that happened on the internet
uh over the years and you can pop your
email address into the uh into the
submit box there on have openphone.com
and it will tell you exactly how many
breaches your uh data has been in and
how many times your passwords have been
leaked and it's quite horrifying
um and so what happens is if you do
reuse any of those passwords uh those
those breaches are out there on the uh
on the on the internet and and if you
have reused your password somewhere else
then attackers come quite easily take
that data apply it to other websites and
effectively log in as you I can talk
about this because it's happened to me
in the past I lost access to my Spotify
account and a Skype account at one point
though I managed to get them back uh it
certainly taught me a lesson about that
oh dear
um so passwords are terrible right
people are reusing them people are using
bad passwords and other websites are
leaking those passwords onto the
internet for everyone to see bad times
so
we have to make it better
we have to make it better and we can as
developers we can help our users and
even ourselves uh by building better
things but of course this comes with a
bunch of trade-offs there's always
there's always trade-offs in terms of
um things online and the amount of work
we do to deal with this the trade-offs
in this case I think are kind of between
user experience and security
uh you've probably seen this you know
it's it's the equivalent of um you know
going to the airport these days and you
have to go uh through several different
lines and security and you have to take
off your shoes and your jacket and what
no you can't bring water through a thing
all of that kind of stuff is like
intended to be better security but it
makes for a worse user experience and
the user experience on the web is is
absolutely important you know nobody's
coming to your web application or your
website to uh to do the login process or
the registration process that's not what
people are there for they're there to do
the thing that they can do after that
and so making sure our experience is
both secure but also a good experience
is absolutely key to everything that we
do
so uh where the passwords fall on this
kind of user experience versus security
side of things well it is a bad
experience right we know it's hard to
remember good passwords uh it's much
easier for computers to remember good
passwords and us to remember easy
passwords it's also hard to choose good
passwords
um people are not very good at coming up
with random things for every site they
they go to
um we need password managers to
absolutely make this easier like
requiring a third-party piece of
software for this is not a good thing
on the security side of thing side of
things it's also bad
if people pick easy passwords they're
easy to break you can just kind of try a
whole dictionary of passwords against
somebody's account and eventually you'll
get in if they're an easy password
if they're difficult passwords they're
still getting leaked onto the internet
uh and um and and people can use those
credential stuffing attacks and then
finally there's phishing right I haven't
even mentioned fishing but uh but that
happens all the time as well
um your passwords are the most
vulnerable to phishing attacks where
people you know email out links and get
people to sign in and steal their
credentials that way
so password's bad our first answer I've
said it a bunch of times already today
is to use a password manager
um
and the password manager makes things a
bit better right the experience is
suddenly a bit better it's easy if you
have a password manager to pick a good
password because it can generate a
random one for you and save it in fact
you never need to know it somebody said
they somebody said earlier uh right they
never reuse passwords and never even
know them and that's perfect perfect for
passwords and so you don't have this
repetition problem either if your
password's leaked from one site it's not
going to be a problem for all your other
accounts
on the security side of things uh it's
also better right they are long
difficult passwords so people can't just
use a dictionary attacking on them
they're unique passwords so they can't
be uh credential stuffed but they are
still vulnerable to phishing
um so uh you know your password manager
is probably not going to suggest uh also
suggest the the password for a website
if it's a phishing site that still
doesn't stop you copying and pasting
that in
um
so the security is bad and a quick
question would I suggest brief password
manager I've not used it I use bit
Warden which is open source and I I very
much like using that but any password
manager is probably better than no
password manager even just the browsers
one
um so our problem our problem with
password managers is it's on the user to
to use them that's the that's the thing
only 24 of people used it when surveyed
back in uh 2018 which I realized is
quite a long time ago now that I don't
have any better data on that
um
so 24 of people use a person manager and
we can't expect that of our users so we
need to improve things we need to make
the password system better we need to
make things more secure let's do that
how to improve it well I'd like to
introduce you uh today uh to the
credential management API this is going
to take us from better passwords all the
way to getting rid of passwords and is
something I think we should consider
more uh with applications as we uh as we
build them as we put in uh our kind of
registration and login processes
um
password the credential management API
in the first case was built to store and
retrieve password credentials those
credentials can be passwords and that's
what we're going to see start with
um in fact what you can do is uh use
that password credential API in
JavaScript this is on your front end to
create a password credential store it in
this case in the browser's password
manager and then use it to retrieve that
password back again
see what happens is if we have access to
the password credential object uh we can
we can create a new password credential
using the user ID and then the password
this is a known correct password this is
probably something you do at user
registration when they're saving their
password or at a successful login
and then you ask the uh the browser and
navigate to credentials we asked to
store this credential this is going to
pop up a permissions dialog to the user
that's why it's uh it's a um
asynchronous uh function here asking to
await for the response of asking to
store this credential now you've
probably seen that permissions dialog
before it's the same one the browser
would do without you doing this saying
hey do you want to store your username
and password in the password manager but
because we asked to do it with this code
later we get to retrieve those
credentials again
and so
um using Navigator credentials get and
asking for a password will then offer
the user a dialogue to say hey do you
want to log in with these credentials
um and if they accept that you get the
credentials and you can pass them back
to your server and log the user in
um that is uh is a pretty nice
experience and so this is uh sort of
screenshots from an Android version of
this uh it's just a web application and
um
uh so when you're logging in it will ask
a save to part save your password uh in
fact in Chrome it has to save it in your
Google account which is even better
because it actually syncs with your
Google account and goes to any
um any brow any Chrome browser that
you're logged into so you can sign in
once on your desktop and then the next
time you get there on your uh on your
mobile device for example it will all be
all be ready
and so then when you come back to login
again
uh you don't have to necessarily type in
that username and password uh it will
offer up
um do you want to sign in as this
account
uh and that's cool you can as the user
you click sign in uh those credentials
are given back to the browser and there
and you're on your way this signing in
process has gone from kind of
remembering and having to remember your
password and type it in or enter it
somehow to a one-click process that only
happens in your account in your browser
where you're logged in
I think that's pretty cool
um
in fact it's a it's a bit of a magical
experience if you ever get that and you
kind of just swing straight on by
straight through login not having to
worry about it
uh so the credential management API for
password credentials I think is pretty
cool we get this one click login
experience and no need to remember
passwords they're stored uh in your
browser and possibly even synced across
different browsers uh if you are logged
in across there
um
I've seen a question in a chat saying
what if somebody gets access to your
Google account that is absolutely true
but I really hope uh Google accounts uh
and uh and and some similarly like apple
accounts anything that is kind of very
Central to your use of a machine or of
uh or or of the internet in general are
the ones that you absolutely keep secure
and so uh it's actually probably more
secure uh than um than anything else and
you have kind of Google uh backing you
up there
anyway
the security side of things the problem
is it still doesn't actually encourage
people to use those unique passwords or
hard to guess passwords so it actually
it doesn't help necessarily on that side
there are a few other hints you can give
to the browser to encourage uh a long
unique password but it doesn't make the
user do that so we're still kind of uh
we have these vulnerabilities
so that's why we came up with two-factor
authentication uh two-factor
authentication is probably something you
recognize uh it might look a bit like
this a text message uh to your to your
phone to say hey here's your login code
uh you need to go type this into the
browser where you were trying to log in
um
this is good uh well
it's good and bad if we think about the
experience side of things we now have
two steps to our login our login process
has now added an extra page an extra
page load another form to fill in uh and
and that's a pain it needs another
device if you're on your desktop you
might have to you know go pick up your
phone in order to use it I'm notoriously
bad at getting
um distracted by that I pick my phone up
to get a text message and plug it into a
thing and instead I find myself
scrolling on Twitter instead it's a bad
it's a bad thing to do
and if you're doing this over SMS it
does of course require phone signal
um you can do this via an authenticator
app as well and that's that's
recommended to add as an option too but
I do think SMS is sort of the Baseline
that almost everyone can receive
uh so it's a good one to have
the security side of this is better
though that's that's what we're putting
to factor authentication in in in infor
uh security allows you to overcome poor
or leaked passwords because
um
uh this second factor is something that
you have on you normally your phone or
or an app
um and there's other things we can uh we
can look at later but the security is
much much better you are still
vulnerable to phishing though of course
if anybody can build a web page that
asks for your username and your password
they can build a second page that asks
for that two-fact authentication code
and all they have to do is keep kind of
sending those credentials across to the
real site in order to trigger the things
happening so vulnerability to fishing is
still there and then there are targeted
attacks uh against SMS which are indeed
possible
um
those are a bit too complicated to go
into right now but they really are for
only uh high value accounts because it
takes quite a lot to achieve this that's
why it's it's targeted
um so the security is still a lot better
than just a password
but can we make the experience better
now we've made this security Banner can
we make the experience better Well turns
out yes
um there's some good experiences things
to be added to enhance this experience
as we go along
um
first up just in the HTML we can add a
couple of little attributes to our input
field which is asking for that one-time
password uh if you add the input mode
numeric that's just if you're on a
mobile device it'll give you the number
keypad I think that's that's a lovely
thing to just continue and then the
autocomplete attribute uh if you give
that the the
property one-time code then Safari on
iOS and uh and indeed on the desktop is
going to help you out by adding it to
the autocomplete of the keyboard which
is uh it's a great experience right it
helps the user they don't have to move
to the other to the SMS application to
see the number they just get to add it
in and so that's what this this is what
that looks like
um if you go and log in on an iPhone in
this case uh it's going to send a text
message and uh as you enter the thing I
see I always do this too quickly uh and
you get to miss it
stop it
there we go as you can see just there uh
at the top of the keyboard we get that
number all we had to do was add an
attribute to our HTML element and we've
got this much better experience where
you get a one click uh you're all the
way through and submitted and you're
logged in and this works on desktop as
well if you are fully sold into the
Apple ecosystem uh then if you're on
Safari on your on your Mac desktop and
you're going to log in you'll actually
get autocomplete working there as well
so you go to login the text message gets
sent to the phone in the background and
it comes up as autocomplete right here
in the browser uh if you ever get to
experience this it's another little
magical thing where you would not have
expected that but now you are you've
already copied your code across and it's
amazing
uh yeah so you can just click on that
and and it goes nice
so that's Apple though and it does only
really happen in Safari browser
um on the other hand we have the web OTP
API uh web OTP is is an API that's
supposed to make this easier in other
browsers uh and funnily enough it's
actually just the credential management
API again
uh like I said this is an API I don't
think too many people know but it's
actually right there ready to help us at
all times
and so there's a couple of things you
need to change if you want to use the
web OTP API uh if you're this works for
the text message version of this it
doesn't help you yet with uh app based
uh authentication but uh with text
message you do have to add this uh at
the domain name you're logging into then
the hash then the code now that stops
this being offered up for uh for
phishing attempts
um because the domain has to match uh
the website that uses on uh that's
sending the text message so that's cool
and then in the code this time we don't
ask for a password we ask for an OTP
credential and we call our Navigator
credentials get on OTP with the
transport of SMS
and that is going to pop our permissions
dialogue to the user to say hey we've
got this message
um are you okay if we uh if the browser
reads it out and and we'll see that in a
second as well
um
that's almost all the code you need for
this it's it's kind of incredible
um if the user approves then you get a
the promise resolves with an OTP object
that has a code property which you can
just use JavaScript to plug into your uh
into your into the form so that looks
like this I also have to pause again
because it's so quick you go to log in
the text message gets sent
uh there it is so you actually see at
the top of the screen the text message
uh is being sent and delivered but at
the bottom this is the web OTP API
stepping in and saying hey do you want
to allow Chrome to read the message
below and enter the code uh if the user
clicks yes uh that promise resolves you
get the code you move on uh and so
that's pretty cool
what we've managed to do there with an
HTML attribute and then a few lines of
JavaScript uh is to um turn
a two-factor authentication from two big
annoying steps to a couple of minimal
kind of steps uh that um made me take
you know if you're using the password
credential as well uh go from
um uh like a long set of typing things
into two kind of one-click steps
um
doing this with two-factor
authentication doesn't change the fact
that you will need that phone that other
device and and signal to receive an SMS
but the experience gets so much better
if you are just kind of clicking through
and agreeing to stuff
uh and then on the security side of
things it's just as secure as it was
before uh we now have these two factors
which is much harder to compromise than
a single password Factor
um but there are still vulnerabilities
around phishing and targeted attacks
so
then there's two factors of indication
with a security key now you might have
seen this kind of thing this is the kind
of uh thing that techno Tech firms will
actually have you use in order to you
know interact with your VPN or your own
uh internal uh stuff
um security keys are um like a yubiki or
something like that plugged into your uh
into your laptop uh and uh allow you to
store secure credentials on them and
this is accessible in the browser via
the web authentication API that's web
authen
um
uh web open is great but also turns out
it's just the now it's the credential
management API again but with a
different type of credential
now in this case
um what's going to happen is uh your
browser has to oh sorry the server
actually has to send you a challenge
which is just a random string of bytes
uh that comes to the browser and in the
browser what we do is ask to create uh
Navigator credentials create a public
key uh credential and so this is
actually going to try and create a
public and private key pair the private
key stays on the security key in this
case uh never leaves the security key
which makes it very secure and the
public key is What will get sent back to
the server
um and the uh the whole interaction kind
of goes that the uh the the security key
will sign this challenge uh using the
private key and that can be verified on
the server using the public key
uh there's some other things you have to
set uh with this
um such as the RP that's here this is
example.com that ties it to that domain
so that public and private key pair can
only be used on that domain
um
you also had some user details so this
can be uh discovered later and then at
the bottom those uh those are the
algorithms that uh are popular across
the majority of browsers
so once you've created this public key
uh it returns that sign Challenge and
the public key which you can send back
to the server the server will verify
um then when it comes to uh doing that
second Factor authentication with the
security key you just have to ask you
all the browsers oh sorry the server
will send another challenge another
random string of bytes and this time
you've already created the key uh so you
just need to say I want to get the
public key I want to uh uh get it here's
the challenge and all that's going to
happen is the private key again is going
to be used to sign that challenge you
return that to the server the server can
use the public key to verify it and it's
job done you are authenticated
uh there's obviously a lot more to uh to
this including building the whole server
side of it
um but this public and private key uh
kind of sharing is a much much more
secure again than text messages or even
an app
um so on our experience versus security
side of things this is still two minimal
steps interacting with the security key
tends to include just touching it or
sometimes they have like a biometric a
fingerprint scan or something
um its problem is that you do need this
third piece this third party piece of uh
Hardware
um that like I said you might have
experienced this uh with work but
um you were
that's because uh it is is beneficial
financially beneficial uh to your
business to secure things like that if
you're just building a normal web
application sending people security keys
or expecting them to have them is not
necessarily going to work
and the other thing is the private key
gets tied to the security key itself and
so you'll either need to be able to move
it around to different machines if
you're logging into different places or
you need to register multiple devices
on the security side of things though uh
this both overcomes the poor and leaked
passwords and overcomes uh leaking
things as well uh you can leak a public
key anywhere it doesn't matter all that
public key can be used to do is um
verify things that the private key has
sent and there's also a phishing
resistance as we saw it ties to the um
the website the domain that you're on so
it can't be used anywhere else either
so let's get to fishing there sorry
password let's get to fishing oh my God
no no more fishing let's get to
passwordless Let's drop passwords
entirely
um uh the future for this uh is the uh
is the is known as pass Keys
um and that's what you'll see is the
sort of publicly facing term for this
past keys are what you're looking for uh
but on the developer side of things what
you're really looking for is
Multi-Device credentials because this is
the credential management API again in
fact it's actually just web
authentication again
um but past Keys have a few more
restrictions that make them more easy to
use
this is web authentication but with the
platform authenticator and in this case
I mean either sort of face ID on your uh
on your on your iPhone or a fingerprint
scan or any kind of device based uh
thing uh that uses a biometric to
authenticate a user
and see what it does is it allows you to
verify the user on the device so it uses
these Biometrics but those Biometrics
also never leave the device there's no
there's no chance of you leaking your
fingerprints online uh which is uh which
are much harder to change than passwords
uh and so you verify the user on the
device and then it works the same as
existing web authentication and that you
are signing a challenge which then
authenticates the user with the server
the nice thing about plaskys is because
they are device based they're platform
based they actually are capable of
syncing across your devices and so if
you are using Android and Chrome OS uh
it can sync across there if you are
using iPhone and and Macs they will sync
using a keychain cloud in this case and
I know somebody brought up earlier uh
what happens if you lose access to your
Google account or your Apple account
again those accounts are more securely
looked after
um and and you have the power of Apple
and Google behind them securing them and
helping you to keep them secure which is
better than most other websites and
applications and so that seems to be a
pretty secure thing and then if you are
using cross devices if you're using an
Android phone and a Mac laptop for
example there is a cross device way of
using one device to log into another and
I'll show you that in the demo in just a
second
here's some annoying code uh you see
because it's not all that different to
web authentication you have to check a
few things uh to see if you can use pass
keys and those are is a user verifying
platform authenticator available that
says is there a face ID or a fingerprint
ID or something and is conditional
mediation available that asks whether we
can display a list of existing pass keys
to a user and if both of those come up
as true then we can create ourselves a
pass key credential which is still the
same public key credential but what
we've added is this last section at the
bottom uh that says you know this
authenticator attachment must be
platform that is it has to be your
platform verifier the the face ID the
fingerprint and requires resident key
means this gets stored on the device as
well that allows it to then be synced to
other devices if you need to
and uh and much less much the same as
web authentication that's going to send
that to public key and the challenge
back to the server and uh this the exact
same way uh as you um
verified using Navigator credentials get
uh is how past Keys get verified the
next time around and this is what it
looks like this is the experience
uh so uh there's a you can always go to
passkeys.io and check this out yourself
uh this is an example of me uh signing
in um and creating a new account uh in
Safari at this point and so it's
offering me to create a new account and
then save a pass key uh this is on my
Mac so I'm using Touch ID and I've
created a pass key for my Phillip Nash
at sonosource.com email address there
and there I am I can then sign out with
this and then go back and sign in with a
pass key and it's going to offer a bunch
I've done this demo a few times so
there's a list of them but remember it's
the sonar Source One it's the one we're
using for this
use my fingerprint and again we're
signed in
now that's given enough time to sync
across to my iPhone which is on the
right of the screen and so I can go
straight to sign in with a pass key here
and it's going to offer me that list of
pass keys that I have again we're
looking for the sonosource one which is
down the bottom it's going to face ID me
and then
I'm logged in I'm logged in on my phone
so that's a pretty good experience let's
take it to another browser now I'm going
to go to chrome chrome doesn't sync with
apple and Safari devices but I can still
go to sign with a pass key and in this
case it's going to say hey I don't have
a pass Keys saved for you you can scan
your QR code with your mobile device
and if you look on the phone that offers
you to sign in with a pass key it's
going to give me that same list I'm
going to go to the sonosource one at the
bottom face ID in
and that transfers back to the Chrome
browser on the laptop and signs me in
now I think that's pretty cool and then
if you were building this yourself you
would um build a
a way to
um store another one store a new key for
that for that Chrome browser
so I think that's very cool I think
that's very cool in fact the experience
is great right there's now no need for a
password because the user is being
verified on their own device with their
Biometrics uh then then that sort of
handles two factors of the
Authentication
um it's absolutely no need for a
password or in D2 Factor it does require
a platform authenticator though it
requires people to have devices that
have this so maybe not everybody has
that yet and then it syncs across those
devices as well which I think is just
magical and allows you to um
uh log in uh even if you uh haven't
synced and on the security side of
things we're using public private key
cryptography so it is unlinkable it's
unfishable this this public private key
is tied specifically to The Domain that
you log in on uh and as a non-security
uh professional I'm just a web developer
I I like to think it's maybe perfect
it's so much better than what we have
that's what it is
um and so I absolutely encourage
everybody to look into pass keys are
there other drawbacks yeah sure I it's
not yet in every browser uh I think
actually it's Firefox is the only major
browser that's been dragging its heels
uh and I've I've read somewhere that it
should be coming this year hard to uh
hard to know exactly though
um it's coming browser support is coming
but it's in Chrome it's in Safari uh
it's in all your chromium based browsers
and it's very cool
uh if you're interested in places that
are implementing this uh one password
the password manager has realized that
passwords are on their way out as well
and they're trying to support this but
they also have this pass Keys directory
site that shows you all the places that
have implemented this and I know I've
added a pass key to my GitHub account
although I think that still is a second
factor it's not the full login
experience yet but also to my Microsoft
account so Microsoft are very much
behind this as well as the browsers
who've been implementing it technology
big Tech is behind this and it's a good
sign
so I have recommendations as I just
close up now I recommend we do build in
past key support and offer it first if
it's detected that some user can use it
uh very exciting
um recommendation is still to support
multiple pass keys because people could
be using different browsers uh across
different systems so offering them to
make a pass key for their current
browser is a good idea
then we can fall back to passwords but
still include two-factor authentication
because we have to like passwords are
the worst part of this uh and and two
Factor authentication saves a little bit
even if it degrades the experience a
little but we do have those ways to
improve the experience using uh the
autocomplete one-time code and uh and
using webrotp API as well
and then once you user can use pass Keys
we can offer to upgrade them and remove
the password credentials remove those
old weak credentials
uh so I have a bunch of links I will uh
get these sent out to you somehow I will
share these slides online and tweet
about it hopefully the jsconf India
Twitter account will uh we'll send it
out as well and uh um that's all I've
got for you uh thanks so much for having
me uh at this this pre-event and I hope
you enjoy this the rest of this and of
course uh jscon for India uh thank you
so much and yeah hit me up on Twitter
I'll see you there thank you
thank you so much for that Phil uh it
was amazing you're in your talk and with
this we will be moving forward to our
next talk we have
we have a next speaker who has been in
the industry for a long time we have
Rajesh Kumar joining us
so I hope you all are excited for this
talk
while uh
oh yeah
hi Rajesh how are you
I am good thank you how about you
thank you very much
I started sharing my screen oh my screen
is visible right
all right
thank you
so today my talk is about past present
and feature of EK master
myself Rajesh software developer at PSN
so my Twitter handle is I am Rajesh so
today in today's session we are going to
see like kabut what is ekma script
what's the difference between ekma
script and JavaScript
what is tc39 that means technical
committee 39 how Technical Community 39
works and we are going to see like
history of ecmascript and what are the
various versions of ecmascript and what
are the features released in part of
each version we are going to see one by
one and we are going to see what are the
features added in the recent version of
ecmascript so that is the version which
is going to release in the next one and
in the next year we are going to see
what are the features we are going to
have in future and we are going to see
about like ecmascript behind the browser
so not only inside the browser like
outside of browser like to create a
desktop application mobile application
in the form of a so we are going to make
use of ecmascript we are going to see
one by one
let's start with ecmascript so basically
what is ecmascript the official name of
JavaScript is ekma script
so JavaScript is developed by the
company called Netscape
initially it was the nickname let us
live script and later rename to
JavaScript
so in early 90s Netscape and Microsoft
are the major tank competitors so
Netscape at that one browser version and
Microsoft also add the one browser
version so when Netscape presented the
JavaScript to ekma International so what
is nothing but European computers
manufacture Association it is an
international standard
so what does ekma international standard
does so it is an organization that
creates a standard for Technologies so
what it means is ecmascript provides the
rules syntax and schematics and
guidelines that a scripting language
must observe to be considered ecmascript
compliant so for example today if I'm
going to create a new scripting language
site away cannot be able to release it
so first I need to send it to the ekma
international to approve it so they will
check whether my scripting language has
passed through all the guidelines which
is scripted by them once if it is passed
all the guidelines which is scripted by
them then they will say that my
scripting language is approved by the
ecmascript there are multiple languages
which got approved by ecmascript but
JavaScript is the most popular
implementation of the ecmascript in
simple terms ecmascript is a standard
well JavaScript is the most popular
implementation of the ecmascript
standard for example in like we used to
some companies used to claim that they
are ISO certified company Isa certified
company so it is nothing but the ISA or
Isis standard which there are some
certain rules and regulation whichever
company is following that certain rules
and regulation they will claim that
their ISO certified company the same way
if I am going to develop a scripting
language it has to follow through the
guidelines provided by this that is
European computers manufacture
Association
so JavaScript is the most popular
implementation of this ecma
JavaScript implements ecmascript and
builds on top of it and also it
incorporates other additional features
and AP such as for example document
object model browser object model which
is not part of ecmascript but JavaScript
included on top of ecmascript so as I
said action script and change script at
other language that implements the
ecmascript as well so action script was
used by Adobe Flash and J script is the
scripting language you just developed by
Microsoft but it was not so popular
later Microsoft started implementing the
JavaScript itself
next week comes to what is tc39 so on
this tc39s very important for this ecma
committee so this tc39 stands for
technical committee 39 39 is nothing but
the specification so the ecmas tc39
committee is responsible for evolving
JavaScript programming language and
authoring the specification so basically
this technical committee 39 consists of
various representatives from different
companies including the browser vendors
like Google Apple Firefox unjust engine
developers on the stakeholders and the
JavaScript ecosystem so this Technical
Community 39 is nothing but it is a
group of JavaScript developers and group
of companies so which is using the
JavaScript Interrupters so what they
does is so this tc39 members propose new
features for example so we are seeing
like new features on each and every
version of ecmascript how it got
approved and how it got released is they
Taking Care by this
tc39 members so the proposals will go
through the regardless process including
design discussion specification drafting
implementation consideration and then it
will be included in the ecmascript
standard basically it will have four
stages like state zero stage one stage
two and stage 3 and Stage for basically
five stages the stage zero is nothing
but if I'm going if I'm thinking that uh
I developed a new feature in JavaScript
I want to propose this to have a global
standard so the stage 0 is nothing but I
am proposing here
new stand
for example new property or new method
so and then it will be when it is
considered it will be gone through stage
one and then it will follow the process
stage 2 stage three and stage four is
stage three means almost it is like it
is going to be in the release and stage
four means it is in the released version
so indicating the progress and Readiness
of The Proposal so basically suppose in
case if I'm going to implement a new
feature in JavaScript it has to pass
through this all the five stages of this
tc39
so if you take the history of JavaScript
so JavaScript is born it as live script
in the year 1995 and in the Year 1997
ecmascript standard is established so
that is like officially the version one
in the year 1997. so in the year 1998
ecmascript 2 got released and it is like
only editorial change and the year 1999
ES3 was released they skipped ES4 and in
the year 2009 es5 is released this is
what like most of us are used now so 90
of the
websites are running on this es5
and then in the es6 was released in the
year 2015. so this is like one of the
major revolution in the ecmascript so
because ecmascript started supporting
the concepts like class
modules so basically as you know like
JavaScript is not an object oriented
programming language it is an object
based language so basically we don't
have the concept of like class modules
in JavaScript we used to have the
Prototype based but again the classes
means it is not a pure class
implementation it is like a synthetical
sugar over the Prototype based language
so in the year 2015 es6 was released you
can call es6 and ecmascript 2015 also by
the name of it
version released here and then the every
subsequent TS they released with
additional features like we got es6 cs7
Esa ts9 10 11 12 13 and 14. so es14 is
about to release in the
end of June or early July so the next
versions of the essence is called as yes
next
we are going to start with es5 so so in
es5 it is released in the year 2009 so
what are the features interview what are
the major features there are other
features but what are the major notable
major notable feature released are
strict mode Json support additional
array methods like for each map filter
property Getters and settings and the
bind method
and in year six so yeah block scope
variables like glitter and const so
basically like through where keyword we
don't have the block scope variable so
with the help of latent cons so we have
the block scope variable and the
introduction of classes modules and we
can do inheritance as well
and then Arrow function enhanced object
literal template letters so these are
the features you might be used
in your day-to-day project activity as
well so I'm just going to the list of
features which is released in the year
2015 template literals restructuring
assignment promise for asynchronous
programming iterators swarov Loops
spread the pattern rest operator we all
know the difference between spread
operator and rest operator default
function parameters they type octal and
binary little so why this all these
features are really suggested to improve
the
development activity like to improve the
development experience to increase the
feature of JavaScript to make it like
performance wise also to increase the
JavaScript so all these features are
introduced
so let's have a quick question for
example let's say here I have a variable
a equals 0 to 1 and cons B variable
equals 0 to 4. so I'm trying to add both
the variables like result equals a plus
b
now I am trying to print the value of
result so what would be the expected
result of this variable result
so
so options are like zero four five four
five and three seven white three seven
so either it could be zero four five or
four five and three seven
so the answer is actually
three seven why three seven is because
here 0 to 1 it is not a normal number
like it is an octal number so why we are
getting 37s like because when a number
starts with zero and if it is between 0
through 7 it will be an octal number
so like 1 into a to the power of 0 and 2
into a to the it is like cover
Primary School mathematics so whatever
the number start with 0 and if it goes
through 0 to 7 it is an octal number so
the equivalent value of factor 0 to 1 is
17 and the equivalent total value of 0
to 4 is 2 0 so when we add 17 plus 20 it
is going to be 37 so the answer is 37.
and after integer little begins with
digit 0 and contains any of the digits 0
through 7. for example if you take this
example here we have 0 to 1 here it is
an valid actor and 0 to 5 again it is
invaliductor even if you see this
example 0 to 9 it is not an valid octal
number because it starts with 0 but it
is then following numbers are not true 0
to 7 so it is above the seven so it is
not an octal number it will be
considered as a normal number
so es6 added the support to avoid this
confusion so es6 what did this so they
brought in
literal to support to just to support
this octal and binary literals so and
after literal begins with digit 0 and
contain any of the digits
0 through 7 es5 supports numeric
literally and octal decimal and
hexadecimal es6 added support for binary
literals and changed the way it
represents the octal literals
for example when I say for example let a
equals 0 to 5 this is how we used to
represent octal number in es5 so in es6
what we can do is so we can include this
o before this after this zero so zero or
two phase so that means it represents
the actual number so if I am trying to
print the value of a and b both it is
going to print 21 the actual number
value so here what I have declared it is
an octal value whatever I am trying to
print here it is an
actual decimal value
Okay so
here if I'm trying to print 0 to 9 so it
will print that value it as 0 to 9
itself because it is not an octel value
so
how we can avoid this stress like in es5
we can make use of the use trick so if
you use use trick if for this non
Optical number if I'm trying to include
0 it will throw the syntax at the
decimal with leading zeros are not
allowed in Stick mode whereas it will
allow for the octal values it will not
allow for the non-octal value
wait a second in es6 so we have this
notation o which is used to represent
that it is an octal value and if I am
trying to put it before a nonoctal value
it is going to again throw in syntax
error
and in yes
es5 doesn't provide any literal form of
binary numbers to pass and binary string
we need to use the percent method so for
example if I want to convert any number
to Binary value I need to use a method
called percent whereas in es6 I can make
use of this little to represent the
binary so I can just declare 0b followed
by this so if I am trying to print this
value it will return its actual number
value so here it is in its binary
equivalent its actual
number value is
so what are the features introduced in
ecmascript seven so in ecmascript 7 we
got exponential operator and we got a
array method called includes so
generally normally if I want to find any
particular value in Array whether that
value is present inside we used to write
an Loop we used to write it over the
loop and we used to check the condition
method that particular values present
inside the taryana but with the
introduction of include methods so we
have in built-in method which says that
whether that particular value is present
in say then or they are not
and then in es8 we have methods called
async covet so which is used to make an
asynchronous shape asynchronous APA
calls and asynchronous methods we can
able to make use of this asyncavate and
shared memory and atomics for parallel
programming and we have object dot
values and object dot entries which is
used to convert an object to array and
array to object waste waster and we have
a string Methods like patch start pad in
to add the padding to the string and
then in es9 we have the built-in methods
like asynchronous iteration restaurant
spread operation for objects earlier we
add Western spread operator for arrays
only and in es9 they introduced the
resistance Creator operator for objects
as well and we have something called
promise.prototype Dot finally and
unicode property escapes
I mean es10 so we are the array methods
like flat flat map optional catch
pointing object from entries
string trimming methods like trim start
and treatment so earlier We'll add a
common method called trim which is used
to remove the spacing before and after
the string so now we can able to trim if
I want only at the start or if I want
only at the end we can able to trim at
the start and agent as well and we have
something called for the symbol method
we are symbol.t prototype dot
description and in es11
what are the features to introduce this
begin data type Dynamic importation
operator optional shining operator
promise dot all settle
match all and optional catch binding
and in es12 we got the methods replace
all logical assignment operator numeric
separators promise.ne weak reps and
finalization registry and logical
knowledge assignment operator
in
es13
so we got object.prototype dot as one
property to check whether my object
assets one property in an object or not
and we have the art proposal like by
specifying a particular index I can able
to get what value is present at the
particular index of the array and then
we have something called top level await
and then regular expression match
indices and the interview is private
instance method and accessories in class
and we have something called error cast
so in try and catch block like in our
error handling so we can make use of
this error cost to throw what is like an
exact error message
and an es14 so es14 which is going to
release in the upcoming month so es 14
is expected to release in the end of
June or early July of 2023. so what are
the methods
we are going to have in this es23 is
like es2023 is change array by copy
array find from last Ash Bank grammar
and symbol AS big map Keys okay so you
will go one by one first so regular
normally we have a reverse method in
Array so which is used to reverse an
array for example let's say here I have
an array which is having the value one
two three normally if I want to reverse
that so I have created another variable
called Target array and then my original
so in the Target array my value is going
to get reversed but what this reverse
method does is it is going to mutate my
actual array as well so in case if I
want to avoid this mutation so what I
can do is so they introduce this method
called two reversed RG narrator to
reverse so it is going to be affect only
the target array whereas the arch in
Array going to Remains the Same so
that's the difference between reverse
and two reverse reverse is going to
mutate our original array to be reverse
this not going to mutate the original it
is going to
change effect only the targeted array
the same way like normally if I want to
sort the values in another like normally
you see method called Sir okay sort will
mutate an actual array so in case if you
think that I don't want to mutate an
original array so we can make use of the
method to sort it so the same difference
like whatever we seen the difference
between reverse and to be reverse same
applicables to certain to sorted
why we use place in JavaScript to remove
that particular value from another index
or to add so to modify the array we may
use this place method okay displacement
will mutate and actual array so two
spaced it is going to be affect only the
target error it is not going to affect
the whole cylinder
and then we have something called r8r
prototype dot width so here for example
here I have my origin array one two
three
and then here
originally F1 here I'm trying to change
the value and here I'm trying to print
the value again it is going to affect
the original array so here
I'm using the method curve with so that
means I am going to replace this with
the targeted array so where is my
original array Remains the Same in the
targeted array only I'm just going to
replace this index 1 with whatever in
index we have the index of one we have
the value 2 so it is going to replace
with 5.
so on the next new proposal which we
have
es 2023 is RA fine from last so in Array
so we are going to get a new methods
called find last find last index so
which is going to find the values of the
array from we add this kind of method
for our string earlier now we are going
to get it for our array prototype as
well
and we have something called ashbank
grammar so ashbank is a sequence of
character at the beginning of an
executable script that defines The
Interpreter for the program to be run
for example like for example when an
Unix kernel program loader executes a
JavaScript program the host strips the
ashbank to generate a valid source
before passing it down to the engine so
to add the ashbank command so we can
make use of this hashbank comma so which
is going to be used by the interrupter
so what are the features which we are
going to expect in the like 2024 like
So currently which is in the stage two
so like yeah we can expect like pipe
operator iterator helpers new set method
decorators array grouping and much more
so we can expect in the upcoming
releases of the Atma script okay so far
like whatever the features we have seen
so far which we normally used inside our
browser but tecmascript is not
restricted only for the browser so it
must can be used outside of the browser
feature as well so while the ecmascript
is widely known as the standard for
JavaScript in a process however
ecmascript is used behind the crossfx
and plus we all know node.js server side
implementation of JavaScript so node.js
also we are making use of this
ecmascript features as well so desktop
application with Frameworks like
electron developer can make use of the
ecmascript to build the desktop
application so electron internally uses
chromium and node engine
and we can also develop a mobile
applications using the framework like
react native or native script enables
the development of mobile application
using the itmascript and apart from that
we can make use of the ecma script in
the iot as well so ecmascript is
increasingly
used for iot development platforms like
Johnny fi and Tesla leverage the sigma
script to program and interact with
Hardware devices and we can do
serverless Computing so like even such
as like AWS laminate and glue Google
Cloud functions are making use of this
ecmascript to do this achieve the
serverless Computing and we can able to
develop a command line tools like for
example the Babel
we can make yourself take my script to
build a command line tools as well
yeah that's it from inside so any
questions or any
queries
thank you so much Rajesh it was an
amazing talk
we now have our next speaker who we all
have been waiting for
we have the super talented satyam for
our next talk
let's wait for satyam to come up
uh hey hello everyone so yeah thanks for
having me Hi satyam how are you I hope
I'm Audible
yes
yeah yeah just I'm just doing it how are
you
I'm doing good I'm excited for your talk
and to know more about you so the stage
is all yours
thank you so
it's a pleasure to be like talking to
you
I'm just gonna start sharing my screen
with you
in just a second
um just give me a second I'm just gonna
try to
this
is
no hurry I can understand it it always
gets
um some of the other thing happens when
you're when you're presenting the demo
Gods really need to be with us
but yeah
I hope it's like people now
yes it is visible
uh yeah so hello everyone so thank you
so much for giving me this like
opportunity
so I will just start with a small
introduction of mine so I'm satyan Singh
and I'm a freshman at University of
Regina I'm currently working as a
developer internet push protocol and I'm
a journalist like I like to build
projects like doesn't matter which like
language I'm using I just love to
explore different things and try to you
know get something out of it and I'm a
freelancer as well on weekends and I
like to eat in participate in hackathons
and you can even find me on Twitter
using the uh like ID above that I've
mentioned so yeah so today we will be
talking about again like that I built at
a hackathon and how I built it and how I
use different packages of like
JavaScript in order to you know build it
uh so yeah I'm just gonna like show a
small thing that the stacks that I use
for building shark tanks so this
presentation not going to be that boring
like we will be checking out the demos
of how the game works and try to make it
a bit interactive so even the game is
like live right now so we'll be playing
it soon so in order to build it we use
3GS it is used to be under 3D models
node.js with express.js for the back end
and socket i o for the real-time
communication between their server and
client so uh before moving forward I
would like to give a demo of how the
game works so let me just open my
windows
so yeah
let's say there is a user one year
so let's say that is this user name
clients
so as you can see here so it's actually
mobile friendly as well it should be
like horizontally you know how to
playing that so we have uh this uh you
know Arrow functions in order to like
work in Mobile so it uh it is visible
since the size of the screen right now
is a bit small as per as my laptop if
it's like big that it will be invisible
and let's say if I'm moving the Earth so
but like I guess this is the other user
that I created so if I go in front of
him and check out the other window then
like I should be able to see him in
front of me right and even like
let's see is it now
so I'm just gonna close this window and
like in order to like access this game
you just have to enter Shark Tank and
you should be able to check it out
so yeah so now I guess you have seen
what the game is all about and how it
works so now we'll be sharing in depth
on how like how it is created and what
are the things that we did then or do
you know make it work using this
Frameworks and libraries
so first like how the player works and
how socket dial works so socket dial
basically works on the TCP protocol that
is uh
let's say if there is a player one and
there are some more players two or three
like after a video like there are let's
see three players in total and there is
a player one that moves by a distance X
then the player one sends this message
to the server and then the server sends
that message to all the other players so
that it is being seen that okay that
play is moving back this distance so
that's how socket IO works and in order
to like add things like a bullet and you
know like shooting off the bullets
everything is everything is done using
socket only uh there are some
alternators as well you know you know
Implement real-time communication and
one of them is Firebase and I guess like
there are many more that out there but
socket IO is the easiest one for now
like we don't have to do a lot of things
in order to you know implement it you
just have to create a circuit connection
install the library and they are good
so now we will be going a bit into code
how it is implemented and how you can do
it as well for yourself and just you
know make some awesome games and play
with your friends
so I'll just open my code editor yeah so
I I'm gonna hope that it is visible to
you all like
to me so we will be going uh from the
server side first how the server side is
created you know so for the server we
are using like node.js Express yes and
like socket dial for the real-time
communication between the server and
clients so as we talked about it earlier
as well so yeah in order to create the
like ground like let's say if you are in
the ground and you are going out of the
ground then there is a limit like you
can't go out of the ground right so for
that we have first like just defined
what should be the you know hike and
width of the ground and then we have
created a class game object and we are
going to be using it uh like a lot like
later on so we have just defined some
random things like IDs like we are just
using some random number here for the ID
and then this dot X like these are the
positions of the player and for the for
the physics yeah that this is the
interesting one like for the physics in
order to implement physics uh in a web
game there are a lot of libraries out
there like Canon gs1 and then there is
ammojis as well but like there are a lot
of limitations with them as well and you
can't just like use them like was facing
a lot of issues while creating this like
online multiplayer game with it so what
we thought is instead of using them we
will create our own Collision like a way
to like data collision and you know
create physics in it so what we are
doing here right now is we are checking
the position of the players like uh just
check it right now just see this for now
so we are just like uh creating a const
OLX and old y so we are going to be
using it here for detecting the
collision and restricting the player to
move beyond that point beyond that point
like let's say that is a wall then the
player shouldn't be able to go inside
the wall so we are we are going to be
using this OLX here for that so like as
we saw like 2500 is the like height and
with with your yeah so let's say if the
user is going to trying to go like
beyond that so it will just make the
Collision true and if the Collision is
true then it will make the future step
of that player like let's say if the
player is uh you know typing just
clicking on the arrow button to move
then it will just like make its position
to the old ax that we have been defined
earlier so it won't let the user like go
ahead and he or she like won't be able
to you know Collide like go inside the
wall or go out of the map
and if like if there is no Collision
then we'll just return that no no
quality so we don't have to do anything
about that and for using the same we are
doing we are like adding the physics in
the like walls as well
uh using the same uh using same function
and after that we have a player uh class
here which is like in editing the game
object so that we are getting the like
features from that as well and here we
are different things like socket ID name
width height Health bullets point and
movement so first of all socket ID is
important in order to you know check
what user is where like which user is
where so that's what we have like uh
added it here so later on we will be
like uh adding the socket ID as the ID
that we are using that we are getting
from the socket dial itself like
whenever a new player joins it gets a
random ID from circuit IO so we are
going to be using that later on so for
the nickname we have if you remember we
have a home screen like this
yeah
uh this one so if you go here so we have
a input section here
yeah the period that takes a while to
load
yeah so we have our input section here
and where we can you know click on let's
go and we have take more things like uh
stats and like points like if you join
the game it will show the points as well
so for the input section we are taking
the uh you know value from the input
section and then showing it here
then just adding it to the object
nickname and this is the height and
width of the player that we have
predefined and this is the maximum
health and like the point will be zero
and the bullets is going to be an object
and the movement are gonna be object as
well since we are going to be adding it
later on like uh whenever we get a event
triggered from the client side then we
will add it here using socket IO so I
will just show it later on like once the
once that code is added here so yeah so
these are just some of the functions
that we are going to be using like the
shoot function and one more thing like
if you play the game so you can't shoot
more than five bullets so that is the
reason behind this like let's say if
there is a player and if it continuously
like this like keeps clicking on the you
know space button to shoot then it can
shoot like hundreds of bullets at a time
so that's not something that we want
like it will just you know create mess
and like the the game can get a bit
laggy since we are we are currently
using a free video so we don't want that
really important that so what we did is
a user can't shoot more than five
bullets and it will check if the user
has the how many builds the user has and
if it has you know more than five
minutes then it will just return none or
else it will create a new bullet with
the height and weight here so it will
just send this details to the front end
and later on we will be checking
different as well how we have used three
just in order to create this like
bullets and you know player that we saw
earlier and for the damage like it is
checking which bullet is you know it is
acting with which player so if let's say
if a player like uh if a bullet hits a
player two then it the that player's
health will decrease by one and let's
say if the Players Point like health is
zero then it will just remove that
player and Amit uh updated player list
that we are going to be checking like
let's say it is emitting the updated
player list here right so this is how
like socket dial works so this is a
recognized explanation about it so let's
say if we go here and check where we are
listening to updated player list so
whenever a player dies so it will just
you know emit that upgraded player list
event and yeah on the like on the front
end socket like socket dial is already
open it's not like uh HTTP protocol
since it's following the TCP protocol so
it's always on so it's checking the like
checking for the you know events getting
triggered so if there is a event
triggered as like updated player list
that we have mentioned there so it will
just like console log about it and you
know add that the player died in the
stats if you have seen that
in the left left hand side of the game
you should be able to see a stat like
this that cloudstone or like anyone if
dies or like joins the game it will show
it to you so that's how we are doing
that and that's how socket dial works
and this is how like it's not gonna like
another example of if a player joins
then just like check for that particular
event getting
and then add them in the list and show
it to the stats
so yeah and in order to remove the
player it is just deleting its ID and
you will have to delete the deleted
socket ID from the you know socket IO so
yeah and later it's just like returning
it in the Json format
and that that's all about how player is
created and now it's the same for the
bullet like bullet is getting in the
same way we are defining the height and
width of it and like object player like
we are cutting the player as well from
the game object so yeah
and after that like once we remove it
like it deletes the like let's say if
there is if the bullet collides with the
map like end of the map where the
bullets like disappear uh as well like
it just deletes from the gets deleted
from the socket IO as well as well as
from the map
and we have a small like board player as
well so in case you go in the game you
will always see a player name as Karthik
and he will be like you know this
always like keep dying and if you like
spawning everywhere so yeah that that's
that's it and later on we have like
walls so we have predefined the wall
site with and positions here so
initially we had a random one but for
that we have to like share the you know
shared position from the back end to the
front end but that's not something we
want in order to you know you know in
case we are using a free tier free tier
of server so in order to decrease the uh
you know
decrease the lagging we have to remove
it and we have just hard like hardcoded
here the positions of the walls and yeah
that's how the walls are yeah and every
wall has ID as well and this is uh like
just a Robot Layer and this is how we
have initiated the socket IO so uh like
I have been talking a lot about socket
is like just mix the mix it a lot easier
in order to like you know Implement
real-time communication like let's say
if you are using some other like some
other platform in order to use the real
time thing you you have to first like
get that API key initialize it and we
have to do a lot of things but here you
don't have to do it you just have to
like install the library and then just
you know just Define it above and then
you can just like do this that I O DOT
on connection that if on connection then
it will do these things and like let's
say uh on connection is the thing that
will happen like very first like let's
say when the game is started like game
is just loaded then the connection will
be uh triggered or automatically and
after that we can just create like
different kind of uh events to get
triggered whenever a player joins the
game or shoots something or do something
else so yeah let's say if there is a
game start uh games are uh event
triggered so it will just clear create a
new uh player and add it to the player
object that we have defined above with
the with its socket ID and nickname
nickname is something that we are
testing from the front end that we
showed earlier and it will just add the
socket ID to it as well so that we are
tracking like which player is alive and
which player is not and with the help of
that we can do a lot of different things
as well since like you can uh access the
details from it like we are we have all
the details like you know which player
which bullet is like intersecting with
this player so a lot of other things can
happen like can be you know added here
as well and by the way like it's open
source too so in case you want to add
something Channel then you can do that
as well and in order to like add the add
the name of the player that is getting
you know spawned or like removed we are
just like checking the name of the
entire like checking all the names that
are in the in the array and then slice
into the last one the latest one we can
say uh and that that works like that's
not the ideal way to do but it's working
so yeah
and once the like player joins or like
dies so it will just you know uh like
trigger this uh particular event that is
joining list and send an in to that like
send the name to the front end so we
will be accessing it like in the front
end actually check it out and same way
we have like player movement and shoot
and disconnect like if you're a player
disconnects then just remove it from the
uh from the game and just remove its ID
as well and then we have like uh yeah so
this is important so in order to get the
gaming Loop we have uh created this set
interval and it is like
working on like 20 FPS I guess and after
that we are accessing some of the uh
like index.js and HTML files from the
public folder that we have created
earlier so that's how the the backend
actually works here so backend was the
tricky of that but now we will like jump
into front end that right we have used
3GS and done some like amazing things
there so first I'll just show you how
maps maps work okay so already uh three
years have a lot of different uh you
know predefined models that we can use
so we don't have to like always create
something like just create a new model
and then just you know uh integrate it
from uh yeah we can do that but in order
to create an online game uh I guess
that's recommended for now because it
can add like traffic like add a lot of
lagging in your game so that's something
that I did but I've figured out that it
is not a good way so I removed it so
they already have like a lot of
different uh like 3D models that you can
use so we are currently using a box
geometry and mash material in order to
add the colors and all so this is the
flow for now like we have added the you
know
a particular uh here just the shape and
geometry and the color and we have added
the camera as well the camera is here so
we can uh like change the cameras as
well like we can just focus on the
player or just like make it far away
there are different ways to do that and
for the and in order to like initiate it
we have used the constant which does
like three dot C so it initiates the
entire front end thing
so now like that is lighting as well and
this actually confuses a lot of people
since it is confusing because like uh in
order we have to like check like from
where the light should be coming from so
that we can add like shadows as well in
again like Shadows just adds you know
the kind of things that we can think
that okay this is something uh you know
we can see uh we can see a bit realistic
yeah so that for that uh we have to like
pay attention on adding lights and how
from this direction the light is coming
from and what should be the color of
light so we can do all that for using
this and in order to like just add their
life we have just uses scene dot app
right and scene dot add NBN
and now we can just go in the front end
of like where we are using all these
things and just creating our players and
all so uh if you've seen the game
little bit Yeah so if you can see in the
game there is the entire
environment you're like you can see
those things but actually that's that's
not earlier thing like you can't go
about like Beyond this thing so it's
actually image that we are using and
using it as a cube kind of image so that
it complete like completely takes up
like takes the environment and shows it
like a complete Globe kind of thing so
in order to use it uh we have used the
three uh texture loader from 3GS and
just added it here so there are like the
images are in a public folder and then
using it from there to here in order to
use it and we have the one texture blood
texture at the same way we are just
using the texture loader dot load from
3GS and then adding it here
here is the player material so
this was the toughest doing right now
like like if you can see so basically
this is just a cube this is not a real
tank kind of model so it's just a cube
but in order to make it more like a tank
so we just downloaded couple of images
and then added it in such a way so that
it looks like a tank so it's it's
basically just a queue right now but
yeah it looks like a tank if you see it
from yeah from our perspective
so yeah so here are the like uh images
that we loaded from here and then just
added some kind of colors in order to
make it look nice and then we have like
a phone loaders in order to show those
3D uh 3D phones here so it shows like
this to me but if there is a player in
front of me it will be like you know uh
a waste so that they can read it
so yeah so yeah we can see the loader
map that it is loading the uh like
entire map that is Cube texture loader
and all that we have above and we're
adding the textures there as well and
then we are yeah this is this is
important in order to animate the like
animate the entire thing in the front
end so we are supposed to add it here
and just create this request animation
frame and then add the animate uh inside
it and then just calling it your
now uh we will start with the game like
game start so if you remember when we
were starting the game we were supposed
to add our name inside the input section
so here what it is what it does is it
just like it's nothing like rocket
science just change the value and checks
if the value is less than particular
value and if it less than it will just
say that you know just enter the name
and if it is like greater than 10 it
will just say no just reduce the name so
that's how like if it uh if it's
everything everything is good then it
will just emit this function that is
game start that we saw in the server
that if a game starts then it will just
create a new player with that socket ID
as the player ID so that's how like it
is being triggered from here and then
the like in the server it checks that
okay on GameStop it will do this kind of
things that is adding the ID to it and
the nickname that we are passing from
here so when we are passing it from here
so we can just access it here using the
game
yeah so it's so as you can see we are
accessing the nickname
that's all uh like socket dial Works
actually so I I hope like till the end
of the talk you will at least know how
like socket dial works and how to use it
in your own games
so that's how yeah so once you have like
clicked on okay yeah enter the game then
it will just store your uh you know show
your nickname inside the local storage
so that it doesn't show the model like
whenever if you are new to game it will
show a model how it works and all so in
order to not show it again and again to
make it you know a bit uh confusing for
people and a bit irritating so we just
thought that once the player like joins
the game it will just add a local
storage to it and it will like next time
if the player joins it will check if the
local storage is empty then it will uh
like show the model and if it is not
empty uh sorry if it's not empty then it
will not show the model but it is empty
then it will show the model of like how
the game works and all and in the same
way we have used three years in order to
play some music uh which gets a bit
annoying sometimes but yeah it is it is
so yeah so yeah we are just like
accessing all the events that we
triggered in the back in the back end so
that we can do the things that it we
were supposed to and taking all the
functions from the backend as well like
whenever
event is being triggered we can send
some push like some things with it as
well like we did for the nickname and
update players and all
yeah
and yeah these are just some small
things on how like it works and
this is for the you know uh for the for
making it a bit uh user friendly for
playing in phones so it is actually
currently user friendly in one as well
but since it's in that so it doesn't
give that kind of feeling but yeah still
it works in in phones as well
so yeah that's all about how the entire
thing is working for now and we have the
state like if you remember in the back
end it was like emitting a state where
it was emitting players bullets and
balls so we haven't used walls here
since we are just pre-recording it like
just hardcoding it uh in our front end
back-end as well so yeah that that's how
the entire thing works and we are just
using uh some like already pre-built
models like the boxometry for the player
but in case you want to use your own
models like let's say you have to you
are like just like a lot creative and
you want to just build your you know own
model and then use it in your game then
you can do that as well so for that uh I
did coded it here but yeah it makes the
game a bit laggy in case you want to
just build a online game but yeah if you
if you have like a kind of a premium
subscription maybe then it won't so we
are actually using a Railways which is
which provides a pre a free subscription
for like you know users so for that like
it can get laggy you are using like
custom models but it is possible to use
it you just have to like just do this
and it should work
but for now we are using the Box
geometry from three mesh
and then yeah this is for the shadow
thing that we added from the lights and
then we are just adding some fonts so
that it's 3D and checking the player
socket ID and giving it a score so that
like we will play the game as well after
this so you can see how it works and on
so yeah that that's how the entire like
game looks like and how you can build it
and at the end like if this like player
dies then it will just you know remove
that particular thing and just take that
to the home screen
so that that's how that's the entire
code of how it works so in case you want
to check it out what you can do is you
can just enter this link that is shark
tanks.tech and this this open the game
and you should be able to access it and
play it with your friends and in case
you want to like you know play play with
anyone you just have to share the link
you don't have to do anything else it's
just like really easy this go let's go
and you should be able to access it I
hope like not many people will open it
or else it will go down
so yeah that that's the entire code how
it works and all so except that like
there are different ways in order to
like create uh create like JavaScript
based games in that and one of the uh
most useful libraries that I've been
using is 3js since it makes a lot easier
to add 3D 3D models inside your back
back up I I am I'm sure like most of you
have seen those uh you know websites
like the Apple ones so they create some
sort of models that scrolls with you or
like do some sort of you know rotation
and all so even those things are done
using three years so in case you want to
check it out just like definitely go and
check it out you can even build like
different things like your own portfolio
if you remember like there was a
portfolio well invited by Bruno Sam I
guess you can do the portfolio with a
car where he drives it around and shows
what he has done and all so in order to
do all those things you are supposed to
use 3GS you can even use like the three
in in case you are using their you are
using react.js and there are like new
things as well coming uh in react like
they just made some announcement about
it last week so hopefully we will be
able to add physics more easily this
time and in case just a suggestion in
case in case you are building it uh
Insider react how about the app and you
know like you're use building it using a
game and you want to just make it an
offline one and not an online one then
definitely check it out check out Canon
share so Canon JS is basically a physics
library that that adds physics to all
your objects so in case you want to do
it then just try to use uh like Canon JS
ammojis is also an option but it can get
update uh daunting for someone new in
case there is someone new who is trying
to get into the game develop manual
languages and like explain everything
else and yeah so that's that's all about
the game how it works and all so you can
check it out on short pants on this
website that is below and you can even
connect with me using all the links that
I have added in this particular QR code
hopefully it should work I haven't tried
it but yeah it should work so there is
the link of Bangkok so if you open it
you should be able to see the wrapper
that I've created for Shark Tank so it's
like as I said it's open source so if
you want you can even like try to you
know add something
that let's add some features that you
want to add and just you know try to
share it with your friends or play with
them so that that's all about how the
game works and how it is and you can
even like any done if you have any
question regarding 3GS or you have three
then definitely if you do just you know
ping me and really fortunate to be able
to like give my first talk at just
conference India and I guess I am the
youngest one this time for the free
event so really glad to each other as
well so yeah that that's all about her
presentation
yeah thank you
thank you so much
I think your mic is on somebody's
Microsoft yeah
no no it's fine
um I love your talk and very creative
name with calling it Shark Tank I hope
uh also go and start your repository the
fact that it's an open source project
but once again thank you so much for the
talk we have our next speaker joining in
uh our next speaker is bye bye
yes we have a next speaker joining in
and we have hanuma on the stage
hi Hanuman how are you good good how are
you
I am just listening to all the amazing
talks and making as much notes I can but
yeah the audience is excited for to hear
from you and the stage is all yours
okay they have been wonderful speakers
right right a lot of good knowledge so
far
all right
um I hope you can see my screen can
someone confirm
okay so let's get started hey everyone
Thanks for tuning in so today we are
going to talk about a library that is
actually making a lot of news in the
industry which is Lang chin so the
reason why I chose this topic is we have
been hearing about terms like GPT GPT
3.5 GPT 4 then charge GPT Google part
right so all these are
um coming from the generative AI world
so every now and then something happens
in our lives and on our lives changes
forever right so in my opinion
generative Ai and charge GPT are two
things that are actually changing the
course of Our Lives as Developers
so today what we are going to do is we
are going to look at what is generative
Ai and we are going to look at
powerafiller lamps and then a bit of
Lang chain and we also understand what
are the key Concepts in Langston and
then we'll look at couple of demos
so one disclaimer so I'm not an a expert
by any means and in this session we are
not going to cover all the concepts
which are related to generative AI open
a or line chain
so okay what is generative AI
generative AI is a part is a type of
artificial intelligence that can
actually create content now when you
think about content content can be in
several forms it can be text it can be
image or it can be any other media
formats now generative AI is also
something that is actually rapidly
developing the field uh developing uh
it's a developing field in which there
are wide range of potential apps
applications it is also going to
revolutionize the way we are going to
build apps
and there are a lot of Industries which
can actually adopt and embrace
generative AI
so what is it about so generative AI is
actually a subset of deep learning and
it is actually a data model it's a not
not just a data model it is a machine
learning model which is actually trying
on massive amounts of data that is
formed across the internet
so if you take a simple example of a
prediction machine learning model what
happens is if given input and gives you
an output
so the output could be a probability it
could be a classification or it could be
a number
now when you talk about generative AI it
differs slightly you give the input you
give a text prompt or something of that
sort you get an output but your output
could typically be image it could be
audio or it could be natural language
again when we say natural language it is
something that humans understand
right so couple of examples like chart
gbt Google bud are a couple of very
popular tools that are actually built
using generative AI models
so all the things are fine but what is
llm because this is the term that we
have been hearing for the last six to
eight months right
so large language model is also a part
of deep learning it's a subset of deep
learning again but it is actually a
model for generating human-like text
it's again trained on massive amounts of
data when we say maximum amounts of data
you can think of an order of petabytes
so it generates output based on the
input patterns and these input patterns
are basically coming from the training
data on which it has been trained
so uh sometimes it can actually give you
incorrect or nonsensical information and
at times it could be sensitive and
offensive as well
if we look at the application landscape
right there are a lot of applications of
generative AI if you look at text for
example we can actually do text
translation text summarization you can
actually chat you can actually write
poems and the size and then blog posts
image Generation image design and then
coding when you come when it comes to
code you can ask it to generate the code
you can ask it to document your code
then it can actually help you in
refactoring your refactoring your code
as well as it can actually convert text
to SQL as well and then there are a
couple of other applications as well
now Lang chain is a library that is
actually helping the developers in
building applications on top of these
large language models so as a developer
if I don't understand large language
model uh until few few months back I
could not do anything
but with Lang chin now I am empowered to
build an application
so it actually supports various large
language models like open Ai and Azure
open AI
it gives modular abstractions basically
it gives you high level functions high
level apis with which we can actually
talk to the llms
and as JavaScript developers it provides
a package which is very easy to use it's
very convenient to run in browser you
can use node.js and you can also use it
in genome
so there are uh four building blocks
in a lang gen when you want to use
Langston you need to understand four
things
one is prompt the second one is chain
the third one is index and fourth one is
agent now what is a prompt prompt is
basically the input that you are giving
to the large language model asking it to
perform some action
now when you given action when you give
an instruction basically you need
something to help you so that is where
chains come in so chain is something
that that is going to take your prompt
that is going to take your input and
then do some processing and then give
you uh the response back index is
something where if you have large
amounts of data on which you want to ask
a question or ask a prompt that is where
you actually use an index and the agent
is a very powerful tool which is going
to combine all these capabilities and
then do necessary actions
so let's look at the code
so the first and foremost thing for us
to do uh as part of development is we
need to create our development setup
that you can find in this readme doc so
I'll share the link with you guys later
on
so basically what you need is you you
need to open a subscription and you need
to open AI key
so let's run our uh first program right
so what this does is this is actually
creating an instance of uh open AI so as
I said Lang chain supports several
elements and open AI is one of them here
what we are saying is we are asking the
model to call with some text in the text
what we have is let's welcome the
participants speakers volunteers
organizers and sponsors for jscon 2023
right and then we are outputting the
response so let's see what happens when
we execute this program
okay
things are directory
so what is going to happen is now I
already have the subscription key in my
environment variable so it is going to
use that and it is going to talk to open
Ai and open AI is going to give us some
response back so here we can see once we
give this prompt right it is coming up
with some text output
so the output that we received is uh
welcome to jscon 2023 we are so excited
to have all of you here and we wanted to
extend a special welcome to all our
participants speakers volunteers
organizers and sponsors
your presence makes this even possible
and we are so thankful for your support
obviously we need to we need to be very
thankful for everyone who is putting up
the show and we're also looking for root
for an amazing event and we hope all of
you have a great time
now uh the thing with uh generative AI
or these llms is the these are
non-returnistic models
so uh if I want to be a little bit
creative right we can actually uh do
that by setting the temperature
so if I um let me zoom in
if I increase the temperature
so it is going to again execute the same
prompt there is no change in the command
that we are giving but let's see if
there is a change in the output
it takes a bit of time to execute and
come back so uh if we see here uh at the
end we see a clear distinction
here we got a response which says that
we look forward to a great event which
is filled with learning networking and
fun obviously this is what we are
interested in right
so let's go back
now
um let's say you want to build an
application on top of it right now let's
say you want to build a web app now you
don't want the user to type in all this
stuff every time and you want to reuse
this particular prompt reuse this input
rather for building various applications
and this application could be tailor
made for a different conference later on
now what we can do is we can use
something known as prompt template
so prompt template is something like a
string formatter so it takes your input
and then it actually embeds the inputs
that you're passing as variables now
here what I did was I created an
instance of a prompt template
so with this prompt template we can pass
the variables as arguments so let's see
how it works
so here we get back the uh same output
rate there is no differential term now
if I change something like this
foreign
formatting tool that can be used when
you are building large scale apps
so the next thing that we are going to
look at is a chain as I said a few
minutes back chain is something that can
help you to build applications on top of
your prompts
so here what we are doing is we are
creating a template again it's the same
thing there is no difference at all we
are just building on top of our previous
example and here we are setting the
temperature to be zero so when the
temperature is zero you are almost
certain that you are going to get the
same outcome every time it is going to
be a very straightforward response now
as you increase the temperature as you
increase from zero to one yeah the
creativity of the model increases now
what do we mean by creativity so
whenever you give a prompt one of the
basic thing that happens is it kind of
observes all the input characters that
you are giving and then consider
themselves token so once you give it a
string of tokens then it will find what
is the next possible input what is the
next possible token after the prompt
that you are giving so if we increase
the temperature it could possibly give
you a list like a less likely word
now here what we are doing is after
creating our model open a model we are
also creating a llm chain
so this llm chain requires a model and a
prompt so the model is the same thing
there is no difference here and in the
prompt we are again uh taking back the
2023.js company so let's see what
happens
again it takes a bit of time to execute
we get back the text response
so here uh we can see the outcome is
quite different even though our prompt
is exactly the same the response that we
have been receiving from the llm is very
much different
this is because as I said it's a non
deterministic model
so let's say if we increase the
temperature right I'll just comment this
piece out
and we'll change the temperature and
then we'll see what is the outcome
foreign
response right again it becomes a bit
creative and then gives you a different
output now now one thing to note here is
uh the chains are very much uh a key key
part in building applications because
once you have this chain in place you
can do several actions you can actually
build conversations you can actually
store the history like if you get this
response you could probably store that
in a uh in memory variable or probably
in a database and then you can actually
pass it as a context to your subsequent
equations so this is a very good use
case when you are trying to build a
chart based applications
so uh so far it has been very simple
right now let's uh up the game a bit so
here what we are doing is uh we want to
ask a question now uh for someone who is
uh let's say there is a new camera on
your project there is a lot of
documentation that he has to go through
right he would let's say if your
documentation is of several hundreds of
pages it's very difficult for someone to
actually understand and ask all the
questions but uh if you put the
documentation in perspective of
generative AI what you can do is you can
actually build a question answer system
so in this example what we are doing is
we are trying to load a
white paper so this is the paper which
actually forms the uh Core Essence of
the transfer model which is again the
base of these llms the super Ln limbs
that we are having
so here what we are doing is we are
trying to build a chain again this is a
retrieval question answer chain so what
we are doing is
we are actually trying to load a
document so it is basically uh you read
a file you take the content and then you
store that in some database so here what
we are also doing is we are putting that
in a vector store so Vector store Vector
store is something that is a optimized
database for document storage
and open a embedding State when you see
something like an embedding you can
think of floating Point numbers you give
some text and then you are Translating
that into floating Point numbers so that
you can actually find the similar words
or similar text and then find the next
subsequent pattern very easily
so once we load the vector store with
the document that we have then we are
creating a chain and as I said I'd say
retrieval chain and we are passing the
model
again we have our open a model here and
then on this model what we are also
saying is use our Vector store as the
retriever so what it is going to do is
so up until now if you look at this
example
we never said anything from where should
the model get the information from so
it's actually going to open ai's servers
and then getting you the response back
but we don't know how the outcome is
being generated right and rather what is
the source of that outcome but in this
case what we are doing is
we are telling the model don't go to the
internet rather use our Vector store so
which means that you are actually
talking to your own data you are not
going beyond your personal computer
of course you are actually taking help
of open a to create the embeddings and
all that stuff but the outcome is purely
based on the information that you're
feeding it's not coming from internet
so let's see how this works
[Music]
here we had three queries
the first question the first query was
uh basically like what is the paper
about
right then what is attention attention
and self attention are to uh key
Concepts which actually are fundamental
building blocks of this Transformer
architecture
so here we can see uh it actually gives
you the exact information that you're
looking for this kind of summarizes that
the piper is about a Transformer a
sequence transcription model built
entirely on retention which can be used
for machine translation tasks
now the second question that we asked
was
what is attention again it comes up with
some definition again uh the key thing
here is it is actually giving you this
definition from the information that you
are feeding it and it is also
Translating that information in a simple
and Lucid format so that as a human
being you can understand it
then the third question that I asked was
who are the others of the papers so if
we look at this and if we actually go to
the paper
we can actually see uh it's the same set
of others
yeah Ashish
[Music]
whoever have contributed to this paper
right all this
others get credit from from here
so moving on
so one of the use cases of generative AI
is it can actually analyze your data
when I say data data could be in a
tabular format as well so so far we have
seen data from books now let's see uh
what if we were to
ask it to execute a SQL thing
so here what we have is
again we have a data source this data
source is a postgres database running on
my Docker container
and there are a couple of tables I'll
just show them
so here we have two tables
so the first table had like around 10
students
and the second table had around
30 records and each of the record
indicates uh the marks of a given
student in a given subject
now let's see if you want to find the
students with the highest marks rate
this is the queries that you will
typically write
now if we execute this it is going to
give you the students in the order of
their total marks now let's say if we
want to ask this
llm to get us that thing to get us the
list of students let's say three best
students and their names along with
highest marks let's see if it can
actually do
but before that what we are trying to do
is we are trying to create a data source
and then we are establishing that it is
a database and in the database look up
only these two tables we are actually
giving a hint to the llm saying that
don't look at the entire database rather
uh focus on these two tables
then we have a SQL toolkit again tools
are tools and toolkits are very uh very
much important tools that language and
provides so one such a toolkit is SQL
toolkit so here we are passing the
database instance
then again uh we are creating a new
model nothing changes here here we are
importing a function called creates
equal agent
from one of the agents in Langston so
what it does is it kind of establishes
the jdbc connection and then opens your
channel for you to go and query the
database
then you give an input
so here the input is in the form of text
what I'm asking is I'm asking the llm to
give me the list of three best students
and their names along with the highest
marks
and this is for the output part let's
see
thank you
now here if we see it is generating lot
of text a lot of prompts right but we
haven't given those prompts the reason
why it is generating those prompts is
because we said execute the model with
the verbosity as true so when we enable
this it is going to generate a lot of
logs which would actually help you to
digest and understand how this
particular program is being executed now
here we see if at the end
uh we get the output and the top three
students but before that we also see
that I now know the final answer the
final answer is this
but if we go further up
and see it actually had a conversation
it was like a conversation between a
human being and a computer and then they
are trying to discuss what needs to be
done as the next step so that is where
uh the actions and toolkits come into
picture
so toolkits provide an abstraction on
top of a specific task that it is
designed to do and action is something
that can decide what is the next set of
tasks that it has to perform
so let's see let's change the query now
let's just say uh give the list of
students right and their names
[Laughter]
and turn it off
okay
so again it takes a lot of time because
whatever outcome that we saw right
earlier it was actually converging and
then finding the best query to execute
here it actually executed a SQL query
and it got the output now if we query
the database by ourselves to get the
list listing names
we should see the same output
foreign
so on so forth
if we see the outcome it's almost
similar but not necessarily in the order
now let's say we want to
sort them in the alphabetical order
let's see it works or not
okay
[Music]
and they executed the program
now one thing to note is whatever inputs
that we are feeding to uh the llms is I
mean they are known as prompts and the
process of doing this is known as prompt
design so the more you play around with
it the better you get at it and also the
outcome of the llm also depends on the
training data it actually uh was trained
on
now if we see this it actually gave us
in the correct sequence
because a comes before e and e comes
before J
so this is another example where we can
actually use a generative Ai and a line
chain in this case is actually helping
us to build something on top of a
database as well
now uh lastly what I want to show is I
want to show a small demo uh it's a
video clipping that we just recorded
from one of the apps that we are
building using Lang chain
so before that I want to show you what
was the problem
so here what we see is
we see the medications of a patient so
it's in a very cumbersome format right
like if somebody needs to read this it's
very difficult for them to read this and
understand what are the medicines so
here you can see something known as
system infant 325 mg overall tablet so
that is something that we know it's a
medicine
then here we have a couple more names
but for someone who doesn't understand
this terminology it's very difficult now
let's just stay let's just assume that
this particular information is thrown at
a patient right how would he understand
it's very very difficult practically
it's not possible for someone who
doesn't have a medical knowledge to
comprehend this information
so if we go back
onto the clipping
and let me play this now who is the
doctor that prescribed my medicines
when should I take my medicines
all right
yeah
so what you just saw was a solution that
we are trying to build right now it's a
prototype and the data you see I mean it
could be Healthcare but it's synthetic
data so don't worry about sensitiveness
and all it's all affect data and
synthetic data but the goal of uh the
video was to show the power of llm again
we were using Lang change there we were
getting the information from a fire
server which actually contains the
patient information and then we were
trying to apply the prompt designs and
prompt engineering Concepts to get the
best out of it for the patient to be
able to understand his or her own data
so I think with that we are almost at
the end of it
Yeah the code for this demo can be found
at this URL it's on GitHub you can pick
it up right now
and my name is Hanuman I work as a
Solutions architecture deepam
and thank you everyone for joining for
this session
thank you so much
so my thing
he taken the whole world for spring and
everybody is currently interested in AI
thank you so much once again for the
session and we are now going to move to
our next session
so we our next speaker is Josh
and I am excited to have him on board hi
Josh how are you
hey I'm great how you doing
I am doing amazing uh just had an
amazing talk before this the lights
behind your uh screen looked amazing
that's a really cute setup and I think
the stage is all set up for you and you
can get started with your talk
awesome well yes that was so cool the
little demo with the speaking was that
made me happy but hi everyone thank you
for for being here I'm super excited to
talk to you about interviewing
developers with accuracy and precision
this is something I personally really
care about and and wants to make it
better in the world so let's dig in
interviews can suck I think most if not
all of us have experienced a bad
interview perhaps a majority of bad
interviews in our life and there are a
lot of very annoying reasons why a lot
of interviews we've experienced as
people can suck the biggest one the most
meme morphic is that so many interviews
ask these ridiculous questions that have
almost nothing to do with the role that
they're interviewing for I remember
interviewing for a front-end developer
position at a well-known company that I
would feel bad naming and they asked me
to reverse a singly linked list this is
like the quintessential I have never
seen someone do this in real life I
don't know why you would ask me to do
this it's silly
and there was just so many weird things
companies do to interview that don't
accurately interview for what the role
is for they they ask us to do these high
pressure environments they tell us that
we can't Google that we shouldn't ask
for help or they don't make it clear
whether we can
and I have to ask why why is this the
way the world is why why are they doing
this to us it's not good for us because
for us the experience is bad and it's
not good for them because these weird
interview questions that ask these
unrelated topics and don't do a good job
of assessing the actual skills
competencies abilities we want for the
role we're interviewing for don't help
the company assess us in a good way it's
not useful for them
but we can make them better I used to
think all interviews were bad and there
was no way to do it well and then I
interviewed at some companies that did a
good job of it
so I'm going to tell you today at this
beautiful 8 21 am in my time meaning
that there are ways we can make this
better and I want to show you them
and I want to start with some context
setting of the two primary goals the two
metrics that I want to improve your
interviews with
accuracy and precision
because fun fact there is a difference
much like how there is a difference in
terminology between a parameter and an
argument for functions there is a
difference between accuracy and
precision even though no one ever
remembers it and it's totally fine if
you forget which one is which or that
there's a difference that is okay
accuracy refers to how close a
measurement is to the true or accepted
value
meaning accuracy is how close to the
center of the target are you getting
whereas Precision refers to how close
measurements of the same item are to
each other meaning if you were to go for
the Target multiple times would you
roughly hit the same quality of results
each time
thank you to the University of Hawaii's
website I've posted my slides on Twitter
I will post them on slack and there are
little attributions and sources in the
slide annotations for each quote or
image that's external
so let's apply this to interviews
accuracy in interviews
how do we check only for what we care
about how do we assess candidates based
on the things that are actually relevant
the inner parts of the target of your an
archery aficionado
what are the duties of the job what are
the things the skills the competencies
this candidate would actually wants to
do on a day-to-day week-to-week basis
how can we simulate situations requiring
those job duties and how do we remove
irrelevant things from the grading We
Care yes they are able to problem solve
but we maybe don't care that they
remember the particular data structures
and algorithms that are not associated
with the job
that's accuracy checking for what we
care about
and then we should also think about
precision
how do we stabilize those interview
results
what are the interviewers actually
grading candidates on if you have two
interviewers and they grade on wildly
different things they might be accurate
but they could very well be imprecise
that a candidate could excellently pass
one and horribly fail the other
and what do we actually qualify as pass
or fail what are the rubrics that we're
grading them on
and then lastly what are the biases that
interviewers are impacted by what are
the unconscious and conscious biases the
most common bias that I've seen and
unfortunately experience is bias on
degrees whether you have a proper
four-year computer science degree
instead of being say a boot camp grad or
a different type of degree or
self-taught
so I want to go in through this process
and go over these accuracy
and precision things topics areas of
fault and see how we can make them
better
let's Dive In
first off we should go over the
questions the correctly assessing
candidate fit questions how do we make
sure that we're asking the right things
and I'm going to reiterate this please
stop asking questions that are unrelated
to the role if you are asking a
front-end developer to design a database
schema that is only relevant if they
ever interact with databases in their
role
this makes me so angry seeing silly
questions and you might be thinking but
Josh they assess problem solving given a
difficult problem it doesn't matter if
that problem is a data structure
algorithm front-end challenge back-end
challenge shouldn't it be assessing
their ability to problem solve work with
the interviewer assess unclear inputs
you are right they should but if you
wanted to assess problem solving you
should do it with things that are
relevant to the role so instead of
asking Graph Search and and binary
search trees unless the candidate will
actually be interacting with those
things try to make it stuff that's
relevant to the role since this is the
JavaScript conference consider perhaps
for all levels how do you explain data
flow in your chosen UI or state
framework whether it's front-end stuff
like react next JS remix and so on or
back in stuff like Express Mongoose and
so on how can the candidate explain the
the fundamentals of how that stuff is
set up
how do they say debug a crash just from
a high level what sort of tools are they
familiar with do they know how to
console log debug maybe using the
browser or node Dev tools can they set
up a performance profiling if they're a
more senior candidate for a performance
role
and then some practical things go ahead
and implement this design mock-up spec
and so on
I'll cover this later in the
presentation but things that are more
pairing based instead of just asking
them to sit there and write code on pen
or paper or coding
then for the really high level abstract
stuff how can you work with them to
design the architecture of something
this is one of the favorite interviews
that I've done uh I had this was at
codecademy where they had me hang out
for a couple minutes with the
interviewer just to establish personal
Rapport get to know each other a little
bit and then we worked together on
designing a front end that had a certain
set of requirements and needed to use a
certain set of user inputs to satisfy
the outputs
that's great instead of some random
unrelated thing I was actually
exercising the day-to-day skills that I
needed for the job and I was
establishing Rapport kind of like
professional notes with the interviewer
great
so I want to dig in here a little bit
too on these pair interviews
because I know it can be scary hanging
out with a person talking with them but
nothing beats actually interacting with
a human to get to know them
and there are many different ways you
can interview someone interactively a
few that I'm going to suggest operate on
a scale of Hands-On interviewing the
theoretical interviewing
the most common Hands-On pair interview
that you might face is the
implementation one where you sit down
with them or you know remotely Zoom Etc
and ask them to implement something with
you
two more and less common ones are
debugging where you give them a pre-made
thing that already exists and ask them
to work with you to fix some bugs
and then the most high level teaching
simulate that you are a junior Dev a
mentee even a senior Dev who just
doesn't know an area and then you're
asking them for help in a thing can they
effectively communicate to you
this thing that you're trying to teach
them
so let's go through these in order
implementation pairings we've probably
if you've gotten more than a dozen
interviews under your belt you've
probably done at least one or two of
these
ask them to build a provided
specification now the wrong way to do
this is to just give them a piece of
paper or Google doc with the spec and
just come back in 30 minutes that's not
great you want to be interactive you
want to work with them make sure they
understand what the specification
entails be clear on what is realistic if
you give them a 13-page dock you should
probably let them know hey we're not
expecting you to build the entire
documentation
and then of course let them use you and
the internet of those resources and be
clear and explicit about this
no one can ever remember
oh what is it how does reduce work is it
dot map or dot mapped or whatever
especially when you're in this high
pressure interview environment it's very
difficult to to remember all these
little things that on your day-to-day
you would just Google or these this year
chat GPT to figure out
and I highly recommend if someone is
interviewing with you provide positive
encouragement regularly
I don't like it when people are sitting
there and getting the interview done and
slowly getting more and more flustered
because the interviewer isn't letting
them know what they're doing is right
and just pointing out flaws it's very
emotionally upsetting thing and as an
interviewee it could be nerve-wracking
to not know what you do well so as an
interviewer be sure to let people know
yes you're doing great this is good
for the debugging pairings very similar
but instead of giving them a spec and a
set of time and perhaps constraints to
build the spec give them something small
something reasonable to read through and
understand and ask them to fix some bugs
in it
because let's be honest how how often do
you fix bugs versus write new features
I'm guessing the fixed bugs is a pretty
significant part of your role and yet
most interview Loops don't assess
candidates for the ability to fix bugs
huh weird
so very similar to before be clear on
what is realistic to complete if there
are 500 bugs in this 30 file app you're
probably going to be spending a lot of
time reading and not as much time fixing
them and not as many bugs fixed
let them use you when the internet as
resources especially since most bugs
I've experienced involve some sort of
weird I have to look at the docs
situation
and again providing positive
encouragement regularly every time they
fix a bug you should note hey that's
great you did good
lastly teaching pairings this is another
thing that I picked up at code academy
asked them to explain a concept to you
now I will note teaching is another
level of stress on top of interviewing
so you you want to be very careful with
the way you approach this don't just sit
there say I don't know tell me and then
have them go warm them up ramp them into
it simulate what it's like for them to
be approached very friendly like by a
co-worker so tell them hey this is a low
stress interview we just want to
evaluate your ability to teach me I'll
give you a couple minutes to prepare you
can use whatever resources you want but
let's just say that I'm whatever a peer
of yours same level same experience
level roughly I just I'm curious on this
particular thing how would you talk with
me about it
and again provide positive encouragement
now when I say provide positive
incursion regularly I don't mean like
awkwardly just saying good you good good
kid good I mean be authentic in it you
know let them let them feel like you
appreciate them
and the the key thing here that I want
to hone in on for positive encouragement
is
you want to grade people on core
competencies what you want what you
really really want
and whenever they do well on these
competencies that's something that I
would recommend letting them know and
also keeping in mind for the interview
results
because as I said earlier we want to be
precise in our interviews and accurate
we want to have a core set of things
where we know we're grading on and we
want to accurately get to the root of
those things
so when you're planning out and then
executing and then evaluating your
interviews you should know what are the
specific competencies this interview is
looking for
what are the things that we care about
in our roles that we want our candidates
to be able to demonstrate
and there is a cool little web app that
we developed a great form of co-worker
of my named Kip uh the competencies
Explorer AKA engineering competencies
I'm not going to go through the whole
app here but it's open source uh they
actually saw them updating it earlier
this year so highly recommend checking
it out and building something like this
it's a nice little visualizer that lets
you see what the engineering
competencies are for each role at each
level kind of a grid view of the columns
or the competencies and the rows are the
levels
so codecading has four competencies that
I really appreciated when I was there
software engineering design for example
you write efficient readable code
execution results you can break tasks
down collaboration communication and
then also community and citizenship
and I'm going to go through each of
these in order because I think those are
really good examples starting candidates
for the competencies you might want to
consider having
so these are a suggested set of
competencies that I would advise you
consider you do you every company is
different every team is different but I
really like these because I think
they're a good spectrum of what we
should really interview candidates for
and what we should expect our developer
employees to try to be good at
software execution collaboration
citizenship in Reverse alphabetical
order I think
software competency this is their core
software development and design and I
think it is hilarious that this is
one-fourth of the total competencies
the actual amount of coding you do in a
day-to-day job may or may not be less
than half of your actual job
how well do they know their framework
and language if you're a team that uses
graphql Express Apollo maybe they don't
need to know all three of those coming
in because those are specific tools but
if it's on their resume and they've been
doing those things for three years they
should probably at least understand the
fundamentals of them
and at the very least they should know
the language that they've been working
with for the last few years or have
learned recently in a boot camp or
degree
so ask them you know
what are strings like in by language
what is the array reduce look like if
you want to look it up that's totally
fine
a very reduced I personally think is not
a very good interview question for most
people but if they bring up using it on
their own it might be a nice thing to to
quiz them on array reduce is just one of
those difficult tricky things
but anyway do they write spaghetti code
or clean patterns or both or neither if
someone is doing a pair interview with
you and they just keep writing code that
has like four Loops where one would
suffice
that might be a red flag a not so good
and then also it can be very difficult
to assess long-term Health Quality of a
code base when that code base is written
over the course of 30 minutes live but
are they writing things that will
probably have bugs are they writing
react components that take in way too
many crops are they writing SQL queries
and having some sort of weird select
star from that could be easily query
injected with security issues things
that are specific to you are just
general to your language
these are the core software competencies
that I would expect to evaluate in
interviewees
that's one quarter another quarter is
execution the starting to get into soft
skills somewhat call it side their time
management and prioritization
now this is hard to evaluate also in an
interview because it's a high pressure
environment it's timed but generally can
they split the large problems that you
give them into discrete chunks if you
were to ask them to write a feature at
work
would they be able to split out tasks
would they be able to even effectively
designate other tasks for other people
can they prioritize important work first
I remember almost bombing an interview
because I spent like 10 minutes out of
30 just fiddling with CSS Flex because I
didn't really remember how to do it on
the time
that was not good
and can they identify and clarify
unclear environments or requirements
can they talk with you saying hey you've
given me the spec there's a kind of
ambiguity here
tell me about it
which kind of borders and blends in with
collaboration can they communicate
effectively with you
can they communicate their intents do
they walk you through the code that
they're doing or if they're not that
type of person that's fine if you ask
them can they tell you what's going on
you give them feedback can they receive
it and adapt to it one of the biggest
things that I have failed candidates on
what I've interviewed is I tell them hey
I think you're causing a bug I I suspect
this pattern might need to be replaced
and they go okay and then do nothing
with that feedback thereby causing a bug
to me that's a big issue not just
because they've done something
sub-optimal but more importantly because
I gave them feedback which I intended to
be helpful and they didn't work with me
on that whether or not the feedback was
correct the idea that someone talks to
you and you just ignore it is not great
to me
and then similar to the clarification of
inputs and outputs for problems do they
ask thoughtful questions if you give
them a design and want them to implement
the design can they understand why the
design is the way it is can they
collaborate with you to understand the
backing context
lastly and this one may be difficult to
evaluate for in pure technical
interviews
citizenship
can they Community build and culture
build around them
can they give constructive feedback
kindly
in a teaching interview are they getting
more and more frustrated with you as you
fail to understand the thing they're
teaching
can they effectively teach can they
Mentor can they pair with especially
checking for more Junior people to make
sure that they can build up those other
folks if this is a junior person can
they be taught
and again this might be hard to flag
forward many interview types can they
learn and apply industry best practices
if you tell them I would like you to use
a design system which is a set of shared
components and then they re-implement
four different variations of the button
components
that might not be great
so we've got and I'll just go through
these real quick again for suggested
competencies software which is the core
SE DND
execution type management and
prioritization collaboration ability to
input and output
and citizenship community building and
culture building with the note that this
may be difficult to slag for
but oh yeah it's all coming together
we've got our great competencies you may
start with this you might change it over
time I suggest you think deeply on them
let's get to rubrics I learned this
quote last night love this quote the
Precision of naming takes away the
uniqueness of seeing
ironically this is a I think a
post-impressionist artist an artist who
did more vague Artistry with the
intention of making everyone's
perspective unique which is the opposite
of what we wanted interviews we want
unique perspectives coming together for
an accurate and precise results
where we precisely name what we want and
then can precisely screen for it
so now that you've got your competencies
I want you to define the interview
specific rubrics for each of them
So based on those competencies which if
any or all those competencies does each
type of interview you give flag for
and then what is the grade or the
gradient of grading of quality for
candidate assessment based on that
competency or each of those competencies
for example let's say that you're doing
a pairing interview which is in large
part gonna evaluate software competency
a three out of three might be that they
can fully describe let's say the react
unidirectional data flow and are able to
describe passing your parents date to
your children great wonderful
maybe a two out of three which is like
an okay this is fine is that they like
mostly understand those two things they
can do it maybe with help
and then a one out of three which is a
likely fail or maybe see if they were
just nervous or something difficulties
struggles words like that
and this may be a rather laborious
procedure compared to what you're used
to for interviews if you're used to just
going into that room and winging it but
it's really good and important to have a
really well-defined set of competencies
for each role for each interview for
each core competency
because you want to again be able to be
both accurate and precise here you want
to be able to apply this rubric agreed
upon with all your interviews to in each
interview so that the interviewers know
what they're grading candidates on
so you want to Define rough criteria for
passing based on these whether it's a
bunch of twos all threes whatever your
team's looking for
and treat those as starting suggestions
rather than algorithm
I say treat them as starting suggestions
not an algorithm because every candidate
is different and I don't like it when
people just sum up numbers to figure out
whether to pass fail you should discuss
over a long meeting or short meeting if
it's obvious with the other interviewers
whether the candidate did well
it's up to you how to define those
processes it's every team is different
but the last thing that I want to talk
about is diversity because it's
important diversity is really important
and I think a lot of companies still
fail to understand how incredibly
important diversity equity and inclusion
or Dei is for building strong good
morally correct teams in this day and
age
now I'm not an expert here anyone tuning
in for the United States May notice a
particular
aspect of me if you're not being
intentional about Dei you're probably
screwing it up
every culture has its own set of issues
around me it's that I look like a lot of
the people in the industry that's not a
fault in mind that's just something to
consider
and in the states we have problems with
a lot of teams being just completely
comprised of people who look like me and
the general problem is teams comprised
of people who look like each other and
provide very similar lived experiences
which is a term referring to the things
you have built your experiences on
now I'm not going to tell you how to
improve diversity in your teams overall
that's not something I can go over in
this amount of time nor am I
particularly expert in that but I will
say for specifically your interviews
it's important to have a diversity of
perspectives
those lived experiences understanding
what it's like to say go through a boot
camp versus a college degree or what
it's like to be an underrepresented
gender expression those provide a
different experience a different
perspective for your interviews
and it's important to have a diversity
those if possible because it gives you a
better understanding more holistic view
of your candidates
so instead of if say you have a team
comprised of a bunch of different people
assigning all the same type of person
whatever that type is to the interview
try to vary it up a little bit just
using gender as an example try to have
at least one not to dude in your loop
our industry tends to have a lot of
dudes not as many not dudes
but I will also warn you to exercise
caution one thing I've seen teams try to
do is get the one woman on their team in
all the interviews because they want the
woman's perspective in all interviews
and the the core of that is a good
intent but the result may be that you're
overloading the one woman on your team
with interviews and
that that might be you know restricting
her career growth overloading her time
perspective burning her out so exercise
caution here
and another little tip I have for this
is Shadow interviewing a lot of teams
have expressed to me that they want to
have more diversity but their senior
area for example is all white dudes and
then everyone else is more Junior so if
that problem affects you or just in
general you don't have enough interviews
have a trainee or trainer present in all
the interviews have a person leading and
a shadow is what we call them
this trains up the the more junior or
just in general the everyone on your
team to interview well and it increases
the diversity of viewpoints for each
screen
in essence you can almost kind of double
the number of viewpoints in each
interview screen
now this can
present oddly to candidates when there's
this silent brooding figure in the back
of the room so be sure to let them know
ahead of time just like ask them hey
we're doing a training thing is it all
right with you if someone hangs out
they're they're more judging the
interviewer than you is the cute little
fun phrase I like to use
but this is great it's great for
improving diversity of perspective and
it's great for training up more people
on your team
one last thing
anti-bias training I cannot recommend
anti-bias training enough it is truly
one of the greatest things that you can
do to improve the quality of your
interviews
let me express to you some of the biases
that I have seen in people around me
these are real biases of course
anonymized
I've seen people Express that they don't
think someone without a college degree
can code
this and all the other biases are wrong
I've seen people Express that women are
more Junior
yes these are like professionals who
have expressed these things to me
I've heard people say that they think
that people with a college degree can't
code because they only know Theory I've
seen people say that black people can't
code I've heard people say Indians uh
Americans specifically Chinese Asians in
general I've heard all sorts of crap
and I've also heard people Express those
accidentally without realizing it uh
phrases like hmm they're from a boot
camp I worry about their ability to code
this is for a staff software engineer
candidates
anti-bias training will help you
understand the explicit and implicit and
unconscious biases in you things that
are warping your perspective of your
candidates Without You realizing it or
even with you realizing it in an
improper way
cat recommend it enough
I unfortunately am not an anti-bias
trainer so I can't go into detail but
I'd highly recommend find someone who is
anyway that's all the content I have for
you let's recap and then I will tell you
about a little bit about me
uh we first went over definitions
accuracy is your ability to hit a good
result Precision is your ability to keep
hitting the same quality result
consistently
we went over the questions you might
want to ask things like implement this
with me or teach me something not
reverse a singly linked list
we went over pairing and interviews why
that's really useful and a few types of
pairings you can do
we went over the core competencies for a
role while you might want to Define them
for interviews and then also how to
judge based on them
specifically we talked about rubrics for
judging and then we also talked about
diversity why Dei is important and if
you're not being intentional you're
probably messing it up
anyway on an unrelated note hello I'm
Josh I'm an open source maintainer I
built up the experiences that informed
this talk from a career starting at code
academy part of me starting at Microsoft
and ending at code academy for full-time
roles uh but these days I'm a full-time
open source maintainer I wrote The
Learning typescript O'Reilly book and
I'm also a Microsoft MVP for developer
Technologies if you want to reach out to
me I'm Joshua K Goldberg on GitHub
fostudon blue sky
mypersonalwebsite.com and I'm on the JS
in slack so thank you very much really
appreciate your time have a great day
bye
that was an amazing talk Josh I
absolutely loved all the points that you
shared about specifically diversity it
is an incredibly important point today
and yeah I think with with this we have
come to an end of the talks specifically
and I hope the listeners have been
enjoying all the talks until now we will
now be heading towards the panel session
but before we go ahead to the panel
session there is a quick reminder for
all our listeners to make sure that they
have bought a ticket to the jsconf India
from the official website and also they
are checking on the Twitter for the
giveaway that's going to happen
regarding the jscons tickets
and yes with this I will uh move it over
to the panel discussion
[Music]
what if digital could help your
organization change the world for the
better better Technologies better
experiences better tomorrows we're
publicist Sapient a global digital
business transformation partner helping
organizations improve lives through
digital elevating experiences optimizing
data and Reinventing products all to
create a better tomorrow for who matters
most everyone
publius's Sapient
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
distinguished group of experts in the
field to share their insights and
experiences
before we dive into the discussion let
me briefly introduce myself I am nitin a
front-end engineer at razor pay I am
also part of the Paco team which is a
popular open source tool used to build
optimize and ship front-end applications
to production
I'm thrilled to be moderating this panel
and exploring the nuances of web
performance with rst experts
now I will hand over the floor to our
panelists to introduce themselves uh
let's begin with you Santosh
hey everyone uh can you hear me
yes yes we can hear you
everyone hi uh nice to see you uh so uh
my name is Santosh I'm uh I'm right now
I'm in Kosovo so yeah I was just
sleeping
I mean I'm here for some trouble works
yeah so I work for cylonis a company
based in Germany and I'm a Google
developer expert for angular architect
star NX champion
and let me look around uh on like next
step tool and mostly use angular Network
so yeah that's that's it about me
thank you Santosh uh akancha yesterday
sorry I think there is some
disconnectivity should I go now yes yes
okay hello everyone first of all I'm
super excited to be here I'm akansha I
work with the excavator core team I am a
force Enthusiast and I also organize
this Force meetups in Bangalore
so yeah really looking forward to this
panel discussion thank you for thank you
again for having me
yeah thank you for joining us uh vilva
you can go next
hey hi I'm vilva and it's uh good to see
so many familiar faces
um I work as a developer experience
engineer in
Romeo it's a startup in Germany it's a
travel startup and I work mostly on the
developer tooling platform engineering
and all the related stuff and I do do
some open source and all these things
and good to see everybody
yeah go to CO2
uh can you go next
I am sorry I
am
and apart from that I'll be working on
is London psycho Jackson guitar
yeah happy to be here
yeah glad to have you here uh saurabh
Verma
yeah
and the other sort of of the group
I work with Tata one mg I I used to do a
lot of performance growth performance
for them uh and right now I'm looking
after multiple aspects so what the team
does in the day-to-day you know life
cycle
thanks um
hey everyone
um can you guys hear me
yes I can hear you
so yeah I'm on my work as an
architecting fan so I kind of uh
specialize in building javascript-based
apps and then I'm focusing on
Technologies like my good friend Trends
micro services and also performance
engineering looking forward to a very
good conversation
glad to have you here uh Manish hello
everyone I am Manish shekhawat I'm
working as director of Technology public
recipient uh primarily specializing in
experience engineering currently taking
care of digital business transformation
for North American client building
e-commerce webinar for them in re react
ecosystem
my interest areas are open source and
nfrs like performance security
accessibility SEO and open source as
well so glad to be here
yeah glad to have you here uh thank you
all for introducing yourselves and
sharing your expertise uh now let's
delve into our discussion on web
performance let's start with the
fundamental question why is web
performance important and what are some
common performance bottlenecks that
websites often encounters
we would love to hear your thoughts on
this
so I think uh first first thing which
comes to my mind is user experience I
think we all care about user experience
the most
so uh web performance does impact user
experience like if your page is not is
loading slowly or your site is slow or
it's not showing up or let's say even if
it is slow it's taking some time to load
the perceived user experience let's say
if you're not showing any spinner or
user doesn't know that you know what's
going on they will just leave your site
which actually if increases the bounce
rate on your site as well so I think uh
that is the first thing which comes to
my mind uh other than that I think uh it
would affect your SEO ranking as well
because if your site is slow uh the SEO
would get impacted as well and
um uh one one thing I would like to add
is uh since we all are like very much
used to mobile
and mobile experience also gets impacted
because they have like kind of slow
networks so if your web performance if
your site is not really performant uh it
would get slow it would not be a really
responsive on mobile and that would be a
bad user experience again affecting your
uh overall site your users and
everything so yeah I think I would uh I
would now wait for everyone else to add
on their thoughts to it
yeah anyone else wants to show it yeah
just to add to what akamsha mentioned
um the bounce rate and conversion rate
is very critical for businesses and a
slow performing application would also
believe the credibility of the
application right if I'm not the
application is not able to do that kind
of user engagement and then bounce rate
would be very high so that is one of the
uh aspect of or importance of web
performance in general along with what
talking so mentioned
hmm
so let's say you are building an app and
then your app is slow right because we
have a lot of countries where the
connection is connection speed is quite
slow
so when you are building something which
is it a global scanner typically
whenever we build Labs we try to build
apps we try to ship everything to every
corner of the world right now our app
should be accessible for everyone now if
you are building your app in such a way
that it's working in few zones it's not
working in few zones you might not be
able to convey the message that you want
to convey to the users maybe you are
doing something in the back end but you
are not sending that message across so
what they do is the users will actually
lose interest in here so that time now
even hits the brand reputation and the
trustworthiness so your solution it
could be super awesome and few zones but
if you don't focus on performance uh
overall not just limited to areas where
you have high performance internet but
you should also consider areas where
their connectivity is quite smooth
and then try to see how much we can
improve and engage your users so that
you whatever message that you want to
convey could be a blog post or recovery
a transactional website or it could be
something that deals with finances right
everything goes through smoothing for
everyone in the world
yeah thanks for the insights uh anyone
else would like to add some more
thoughts
yeah so I think most of the things are
covered but uh
it's also important for us to figure out
what the demographic is the specific
demographic that
data and what kind of devices
and the owning your website for those
people is going to be the most rewarding
I'd say and
what web performance apart from not
being
unresponsive provides you is Headroom so
that today maybe you could uh ship x
amount of features without uh making
your app unresponsive but if you've got
significant Headroom you can play around
with richer interactions and that could
actually engage users a lot more on the
platform bring some Delight into the
picture some of these things which are
not easily measurable through metrics uh
but that gives you some room to play
around
I mean I think everybody covered
everything with this uh topic nothing
else but one thing majorly I would like
to convey is know your audience I mean
uh though you work everything on your
performance and things probably if you
have solid metrics on who are using your
app what devices primarily is being used
what browser is being used that's gonna
help you more in solving these
bottlenecks rather than actually going
and fixing things for all the general
audience because this will save time
developer time this will make your app
profitable and because say for example
I'm going if I'm doing something like
Ola rubber which is operating only in uh
very big cities with proper internet
connectivity then probably it doesn't
make sense for me to have a mobile
version of it like m.facebook.com which
used to be there in the past or the low
slow version of gmail which we had in
the past it's not something like that is
not necessary for us because at least in
near future I'm not going to operate in
anywhere in the mountains of Himalayas
are somewhere so know your audience and
know your target people is very
important when it comes to Performance
yeah
right
yeah yeah to understand that I think
having the right setup for Telemetry and
understanding the metrics is very
crucial
so they I mean there should be emphasis
on the right set of tools I mean it
could be a library it could be whatever
there should be Telemetry unless the
Telemetry is set up it's very difficult
for us to get those insights
um
[Music]
thank you everyone for highlighting the
significance of web performance and
identifying common bottlenecks now let's
explore the impact of web performance
metrics on user experience
Santosh could you share your insights on
how web performance metrics such as page
load time time to interactive first
content full paint affect user
experiences and how these can be
optimized
furthermore we would like to hear your
thoughts on the impact of CDN on web
performance
I mean first let's talk about the
the delay right I mean of course
nowadays I think people have lost
patience so I actually at this time if I
like your your website is going to take
more than more than two three seconds of
course I'm not coming back right the
users users will always complain that
this this is taking a lot of time to
load and it has issues I mean it's not
like old times where we used to sit
one day just to get our movies
downloaded
so now now it's not there everyone wants
like your site to be available as fast
as possible
and if you don't do that of course you
will lose customers right I mean it's
very important for all the organization
that their application should work first
because otherwise nowadays people have
options right if you if a lot doesn't
work of course I will go to Uber or I'll
just figure out some other app so if you
don't want to lose customers of course
you have to focus on the on the uh like
fast loading of your application this is
where caches cities are very useful
right I mean incidents can
cache everything and then they can just
surf from your uh
your region right I mean they can serve
all the static assets from your region
for example images I mean citizens even
cities cannot do anything if you ever
like
three four MB of an image so you should
always put some effort from your side
that you should have images which is
fast or you are using some tool to come
compress your images and then you are
uploading it on CTN so you have to do
one part of it from your side as well
CDs are of course I mean that's one
thing which you should always have
because everyone has static contents
right I mean there will be some images
which will be available and If you have
a big application then there are expect
lot of images to be there
and same goes to your icons right I mean
many companies of course go ahead and
goes ahead and uses any other icons for
example material but some companies have
their own design guidelines and then
they end up creating their own icons so
make sure you are putting everything
like all the static images from your
obsidian and we have like of course
Epsilon is also we put
a lot of things on CDN because we have
customers who are like across the world
and this is one the latency issue is one
of the concern for us as well I mean we
have seen customers complaining about
the load times and then most of the time
it's just slip of course because of we
are serving the data from Germany and
they're sitting in U.S or in India so
yeah
yeah so I like Santosh mentioned
essentially the role of CDN would be to
deliver the last mile content from users
proximity right so if I'm in India which
is the nearest location from where I the
assets or content could be delivered
right so that the latency is reduced and
even a 100 millisecond of latency could
impact the ttfb right so and and
eventually the whole user experience and
all the timeline driven kpis or the
vitals would be impacted because of that
right so the whole role of importance of
CDN revolves around the same and there
are multiple factors like you can have
digital Asset Management along with CDN
and then you can have a bot detection
and features which are there with CDN
that you can utilize to to identify the
right CDN for you and it is not just the
assets but also content page caches and
caching strategy Edge servers nowadays
people are coming with Edge service on
cdns and they are providing those kind
of features essentially those are some
of the areas where CDN plays an
important role
yeah I think uh in addition to the
static assets right which are needed for
your application your application could
still be allowing the users to download
certain files these could be templates
uh which you want the users to fill in
and then probably submit later on and
all and more often than not these
templates won't change over a period of
time you could possibly consider
residient to deliver these files as well
rather than going to your file servers
which could be very slow
a variety of use cases that you can
actually build on top of Serial and you
need to choose uh the right one because
if you if you pick up a CDN that may not
be having a itsite an old at your hot
spot right let's say your application is
being used uh let's say in central India
and you don't have a hotspot there it's
not worth to put put that particular CBM
so it's also very important that you do
your analysis and then pick the right
CDN for your solution
think about
it yeah you go ahead now go ahead
is that
um site is loading or not
um so to optimize that I think uh one
solution is that just I'm showing the
HTML as fast as possible HTML CSS
um so you can like re-render it any way
possible whether it's SSR whether it's
render on server or Statics I generate
in usse or rendering on edge test
anywhere where your HTML is initial
screen is independent of JavaScript I
think that usually works a lot that will
give you some space to play around with
JavaScript where you won't have to
network on JavaScript where JavaScript
bundle won't impact as much
um to your FCP and ICP so
um I think this pre-rendering helps
there a lot and CDN is again a part of
that where
um if we have like a
static page then it will just let you
serve that re-render HTML as fast as
possible but even if that I think one
interesting part was uh as well
mentioning your audience in the last
question uh when we were
trying to share of c um CDN for the
recipe.com last time
um this is like from a few years back so
it might not be um same right now but uh
that thing most of our audience was in
India and the server was in India as
well so
um we didn't uh we actually tried out
CDN and the server and the latency
wasn't as different uh it was a no shame
so that back then having CDM did not
make sense we did eventually moved to
CDN but that was for like other issues
to avoid servers and just the other
server related issues but um that was it
for the performance season
I think I think just dropping in CDN as
a One-Stop solution doesn't really work
uh looking at how much of a benefit is
actually going to get us uh is worth
evaluating first but yes sadians are
interesting tools and can help us do a
lot of things
something that I would want to highlight
is image idiots right so
all of us do a lot of uh image
computations on either our servers or we
do it before build time right because uh
you're serving different kind of formats
to different browsers some of them may
not support it then you are constantly
making different kinds of requests so
you are setting up a picture set a
source set that is now everyone there is
something that everyone has to maintain
and then 2x3x images for different dpis
of devices
your image CDN can take care of it by
itself so you don't really have to the
developers don't really have to think
about these and you can then also do
Smarter optimizations on top of it where
you can look at the viewport of where
you're going to render that image and
then make alterations because because
they support
query parameters and uh in the URL which
they use to alter the image completely
right so you would apply filters
watermarking uh changing the aspect
ratio everything else and then it
becomes a lot more easier on you to fill
out the application because so much so
many things are flexible and can happen
on the Fly I think that's also one
aspect that cdns would add here and uh
one point that I thought
JavaScript does hamper is LCP because
what if your lazy loading library is in
JavaScript
so that that becomes a hindrance and I
think a lot of people who
put use lazy loading libraries for
images they just drop it in for all the
images so that is something that I'd
highly recommend not doing uh
specifically for your here images or at
least there should be an way to opt out
of the lazy loading so that you don't
end up with that delay in LCD
uh to add up with uh Sarah we had a lot
has been discussed about CDN but when it
actually comes to the metrics about like
LCP and this uh time to interaction and
all the stuff uh there used to be times
where we can we used to make performance
gimmicks for Google or the search engine
separately and for the user separately
but right now it's not the time for it
uh people who are getting into uh
performance newly they read through old
blocks and start implementing things
just for Google which is not going to
work anymore because Google is rating
your site based on real real statistics
it actually collects data from real
users how much time they take and then
they rank your sites so it's very
important for you to uh think the
metrics of performance not just as
metrics but as user experience so uh in
previously we we can just load some some
stuff in the page for first content full
paint uh sap but then right now the user
should be really uh doing something he
should be interacting he should be
really doing some something for Google
to rank you better for your site's page
load data sure to be better and all the
stuff so though your CDN is helpful like
everybody covered a lot of things about
Siri and though Syrian can be helpful in
many ways it's also important for you to
structure your code create your bundle
load your images and all the things so
your metrics are met and the right uh
Right audience or served right also with
syrians apart from all the benefits
about performance you can also have say
for example if you're using cloudflare
you can have rules where you can
mitigate security risk as well like you
can have a lot of security rules you can
decide you don't have to take all the
trouble on doing the load balancing on
your server and all the things you just
care about creating your front end
bundle and all the things are configured
in the CDN and it takes carefully also
it comes with few issues for example CDN
outrages if cloudflare goes down there
for in today's world almost there Intel
internet goes down so those things can
be tricked sometimes however I think
compared to the benefits we get the
disadvantage is a way to less for Syrian
server yeah yeah one more thing is
because you brought up bundles right
another thing to keep in mind is so
smart because uh oftentimes what happens
is we might commit something into
production with Source map generation
that could actually bring down the
performance drastically it could be
working in your machine perfectly fine
but when you deploy it to your users who
may not be having a powerful computer or
a powerful laptop as you are or it will
be very slow for me
so we even experienced Advanced like it
was working fine in all the computers
but in performance on in the production
the performance was not up to the mark
when we actually investigated the root
cause it was like a plan that was
supposed to be turned out to not to
generate Source now eventually The
Source Maps were getting generated and
we turned off and then uh it was like
taking around three seconds to load it
came down to 100 milliseconds
okay great insights uh anyone else who
wants to add anything maybe
okay so moving forward uh let's discuss
the effective use of development tools
for performance monitoring
could you shed some light on how
developers can utilize tools like
browser Dev tools Lighthouse web page
test speed curve Sentry to improve
performance or web performance uh
furthermore we would like to hear your
thoughts on integrating web performance
testing into the software development
life cycle
um
first is the performance debugging tools
where
um like um right now we're talking about
um what are what are things that would
help you in the increasing the
performance side but a lot of these
things might just depend on use case to
use case so it's important for you to
grow and debug and see what exactly is
the issue with website and what is it
that is
um causing the performance issues with
the site so
um I guess one of my favorite one is uh
definitely browser apples where you can
just go to their tools and see um how to
network is playing the role and where
exactly your render is happening where
exactly your hydration is happening and
then trying to figure out and see what
is causing that sometimes it just might
be one bundle that is just chained with
another Pendle that is causing the
period of hydration
um so when is this um going and figuring
out how what exactly is the issue so I
think learning browser influence was a
pretty helpful thing for me so I could
just go and debug the issues another
thing that helps to debugging this
webpage case
um it just runs the basement insights
and it will give you like a good
insights on your network flow and it
will just give you a pretty good
insights in general and what is exciting
causing issues
um Kate Spade insights is again
something that will tell you give you
suggestions on what you can um
um I think I have
I'm usually preferring DL user metrics
nowadays they just give you like a
better Insight on uh they take into
consideration what your users are and
what internet speed they're using uh
they're using so it just takes the other
things into consideration as well but
yeah it might be daylight where it takes
time to get the proper unusual Matrix
after you deploy something
we kind of use a
the the lighthouse um CI check where it
can be up on PR so you'll just get like
an approximate Lighthouse Square it's
not always the most accurate score I
wouldn't say like don't take these
numbers as like the final numbers but um
when you take the numbers at one PR and
the other PR it will give you again I
can put approximate and what is changing
uh in the libraries we've been uh
integrating like the bundle set checks
where we just keep a little bit of track
on what is the size of a JavaScript
vendor in the library needs performance
sorry for interrupting so I think uh
sort of already covered about uh using
the tools the right way uh to add to the
stlc part I think uh when we are
designing some features some API I think
how we are designing it uh let's say the
API or you know how much how many times
you are actually requesting the server
how many times the HTTP requests are
happening or let's say Ru dbquery is
really optimized because that depends
the server response time will actually
depend on that uh and whatever things we
discuss like you know CDN caching
everything if we can consider all this
on the sdlc it will help us you know
take care of the performance from the
beginning
uh
also as a part of code review I think
performance is something which should be
considered like um like apart from the
tools which sort of mentioned uh let's
I'm talking about the code which we are
writing uh what parts of the code base
uh you know can be improved if we could
do it let's say in a more optimized way
maybe maybe using some cash or maybe you
know uh optimizing the logic the
algorithm like you know how how it can
actually improve the overall performance
I think that also plays an important
role uh when it comes to sdlc and uh I
think there are some tools out there uh
for example gory plays one of the open
source rules which actually uh takes
your production traffic and you can do
some load testing on it and some
analytics on it so maybe that could also
help in better monitoring uh for your
website or periodically so I think yeah
that I think that's all I wanted to add
for myself
so I was just saying that the
performance debugging or monitoring is I
believe it is there's no one right way
to do it it depends upon the use case to
use case and maybe one tool works for
you the other tool might work for
somebody else right and it is an
investigative processing process right
in at the end of the day you have to
find the right tool do automation manual
interventions Chrome Dev tool provides a
lot of tooling right performance inside
performance tab memory related one if
you want to do memory specific ones and
then like sort of mentioned you can have
synthetic data and you can have real
user monitoring so then what sort of
kpis or web vitals are you capturing
there right so maybe TBT and TTI might
not be the right metrics to do at a
synthetic level okay or maybe at the
synthetic level but not at the real user
level because you don't know which
percentile of your users are actually
facing problem with your TBT okay uh so
correct kpi at correct synthetic or
reverse version so identify core web
vitals versus the other kpis which to be
monitored with these tools then CI CD
setup yes of course there are multiple
tools nowadays web testers provide
comprehensive reporting then we recently
heard about unlite house right which
crawls the site and gives you reporting
from a lighter's perspective
um and if you put put performance just
like we have heard about devsecops where
security is the integral part of devops
process if you can put performance as
that one I would like to call it Dev Ops
right that could be another good thing
to introduce as part of the process and
for react people who are working on
react ecosystem at a developer level as
well we can utilize the react profiler
and find out which component is
rendering multiple times and why is it
re-rendering is it adding to the
performance bottlenecks of your
application right so there are multiple
tools at a manual or automation
yeah I think the react profiling bit
brings us into the runtime performance
domain and that is something that not
much uh we don't talk about it too much
yet but I think it will start becoming
the talk of the topic because Google is
pushing inp very hardly enough and it
will also start defining uh how you're
getting ranks right because page speed
is a factor in your page rank algorithm
and inp is a core web item and uh so
runtime performance is certainly
something that I would want to look at
going uh further but it might it might
be something that you would do after
you're done with load time and the tools
that we just mentioned I I have a very
simple block definition for every tool
that we just spoke about so if I want to
do basic uh
I just want to check out quickly what my
page load looks like what are my core
web vitals I'll go to PHP insert and run
it and check it out
if I want to dive a little bit deeper
and look at the whole picture I would go
to web page test and I'll see what my
Network's doing what the waterfall looks
like what uh how's my CPU reacting to it
how what are cash how many cache misses
do I have and hits do I have it will
give you a much better idea of what's
going on uh if I want to go further
deeper like money said if you want to
dive into memory and issues there
I think there is nothing else apart from
browser Dev tools that can help you do
it but that can be very daunting uh
browser Dev tools but if if you are able
to get a good handle of browser Dev
tools
there's nothing better than it because I
remember having raised multiple PRS in
Lighthouse itself to resolve bugs right
so just trusting a metric for what they
show in this synthetic Benchmark is not
enough sometimes
you might be leading the uh industry as
well and the benchmarks have to keep up
with you they aren't aware of uh the
asynchronous operations that are
happening on your end and it by mistake
can consider all of it as blocking and
that has actually happened to us
multiple times as well uh so but
it is important for us to actually look
at rum and uh
uh synthetic benchmarks and not be
swayed towards just one thing uh at once
we use Crux I think Crux is the most
General Ram metric uh like rum tool that
you could get because it's a chrome ux
report uh but I think compiling it can
be a pain if someone could maybe add a
better visualizer or tool that can give
people easier insights into their Crux
report I think that would be nice I
haven't found really I haven't found
anything out of the box I we've always
had to create one
yeah I think um how to second that right
we also need to consider the libraries
or packages that we are actually pulling
into our source code sometimes it could
not be our code but it could be a
library that you're adding that could be
the bottleneck
and oftentimes uh it's very good it's a
very good experience and it's a good
exercise if you actually understand the
source code of the little libraries that
you are pulling on maybe there is a
bottle link there which you can actually
fix and drop the recipe are and then
improve and their whole industry
benefits
so uh to add with everything they said
one thing I wanted to add is about
lighters like Source said Lighthouse can
have bugs and also Lighthouse reports
are always influenced by your uh local
computers performance and also the
extensions you use in your browser so uh
if you're purely going to rely on
Lighthouse probably when you're
developing where your website is still
not available on the internet for using
page test or something Lighthouse is
okay but then don't rely on the metrics
of Lighthouse uh very strongly or like
like a Bible and other than that so the
performance we discussed so far is about
all the metrics and all the load times
and all the libraries and the bundle
size there is also a methodologies which
will increase performances like react
window for instance uh where you don't
render your entire list at once but then
you render only what the user sees uh
you can also make use of such ideologies
or methodologies which was used in other
places in like interest section Observer
which detects whether your current page
is active or not so I think this also
comes into performance which when people
have to increase their performance of
their website they majorly focus on the
metrics and not on these stuff so this
is also a good thought point to start
with
um yeah anyone else who wants to add
their thoughts
yeah
so
thank you everyone for sharing valuable
insights on using development tools and
incorporating web performance testing uh
now as Developers time to enhance web
performance they need to ensure that
these improvements don't compromise
other aspects of user experience such as
design functionality and Analytics
on how developers can strike the right
balance between web performance
improvements and other aspects of the
user experience
sure
so just to be clear every piece of code
that we add right or any any new
functionality that we add it is adding
bytes to the system right it is actually
getting shipped to the browser and it
has to be processed eventually but and
in ideal scenario for something to be
very optimized from a performance point
of view we have to come up with better
approaches when we are grooming our
stories or features right how like I
think Wilma mentioned about how are we
doing Lazy loading or how are we
implementing the solution around it how
like sort of mentioned about image lazy
load one in between are we or lazy
loading all the images or only the
specific ones that are needed right
however are chunks getting loaded how is
the content getting rendered is it
impacting the critical rendering path or
not okay how are we putting the
animations right is it on the main
thread or are we putting them into GPU
right a couple of unique features that
we did in some of our accounts in the
previous project that I've worked on one
is optimistic UI okay so that feature is
more like we are not reducing or
degrading the performance of or the X
user experience of a person just because
we are waiting for certain API to
complete on certain user actions okay so
let's take an example let's say I'm on
an e-commerce website and I'm clicking
on add to cart
now that I item to be added into cart we
have to make an API call right and then
wait for it to complete and then show
that message okay item has been added to
the cart why can't we and we know that
99.9 percent of the times the API will
succeed it won't fail right that is our
SLA at the end of the day so to make
that happen can't we be optimistic about
it and say okay let the user click on
add to cart and instantly show item has
been added to the card behind the scene
in case for that point zero zero zero
one person time if it fails then we fall
back to the error message now you user
experience is instant in that case so
that is another way of looking at
optimizing the UI and user experience
without and also performant and great
user experience in that case second is I
think one of us touched upon device
detection or device tiering right so you
have low end devices you have mid-range
devices you have high-end devices and
you can cater different experiences to
them so if if I have a high-end device I
can show animations I can show Jazzy UI
to them okay but if I can detect if what
sort of connection network network
connection is there or what sort of ram
CPU the individual is using on their
mobile phone or devices if I can do that
I can maybe have an A B test right I
don't display animation to low end
devices I don't display certain features
for that matter I can turn off certain
features for that individual and this
becomes Progressive and assessment kind
of thing and we cater right user
experience to write people with their
devices so that is another interesting
use case an optimal experience with
performant experience
great insights uh anyone else wants to
add their thoughts
for me this entire topic is more like
cooking so we start doing something and
we arrive at certain point then we taste
it and we know the salt is less and then
we keep adding it so it depends on use
case to use case and the situations we
are in so I don't see a certain path to
follow here like Manish mentioned
optimistic UI is one of my favorite
thing to do as well uh also in
optimistic us for high-end devices of
course uh when if you know the AP is
going to take on average like two three
two seconds or something like this add
to cart button can have an animation it
doesn't even have to be the plain
optimistic UI but it just can have an
animation of two seconds or three
seconds which is interactive for the
user and at the same time in the
background we are done with the API
already so those things can be done and
it's more related to the use cases of
people and it's Progressive we can't say
we are done with this we can't say we
are perfect in this it's just a lifelong
uh thing to do and it's a marathon for
me
yeah I'd also like to add that it's
Progressive for sure it's also
contextual
so we need to keep in uh context of what
we are actually building whether it is
really needed or not and then uh take a
call according to that because in my
opinion there is no one-size-fits-all
solution here it has to be
experimentation the more you experiment
the more you learn and then the feedback
loops continue
as much as we want to but let's accept
the reality there's not many companies
or developers are actually writing for
end users we write code to just for a
self and even the companies they don't
care about the end users they just want
like a feature to be available
and that's it so that there oh we just
launched this fancy stuff who is using
it no idea so that's that's the reality
so I think companies also should focus
start focusing more on the you end user
rather than just writing creating
something for themselves and revisiting
things as I think we've also mentioned
and this is really important you need to
revisit it's not like something which
you've built a year ago it still works
or still work fast it's it's not the
reality so most of the companies don't
prioritize performance I would say I
mean this is this is reality we have
been all right we all have been working
on Enterprises for many years and this
is the reality that companies don't care
about performance until unless customers
comes that comes like shouting at you
this doesn't work and then finally
everyone from management to see you
everyone comes and says hey what code we
are writing I mean this is not
performance this is not performant and
then as a developer then you cannot do
anything you have been raising this
issue from years but no one cares about
it until unless like it there is one
customer who comes and says it doesn't
work
I think
I'll just add one more point to what
everyone mentioned that uh
when talking about impacting the design
or functionality uh just to keep one
thing in mind that if you are caching
let's say or compressing the assets what
level of comparison are we doing is it
like too much is it like deteriorating
the quality because you are giving more
importance to Performance then that's
that it should be like a balanced side
so that is something uh we as a
developers should be aware of and
sometimes like I have experienced this
that sometimes if we try to over cache
it it leads to like uh you know old
content like the user will be seeing
some still content which is not at all a
good experience
so it's basically having a balance
between performance and no like not over
over doing something can turn out the
other way around so that is something uh
to be aware of
over engineering doesn't work in all the
scenarios right and also balance between
quality and performance and we have
faced these kind of scenario time and
again right and to add to what Santos
was saying I have seen in the last
decade or so the perspective of clients
and the organizations is changing they
are now coming uh taking performances
one of the primary aspect and they're
coming towards yeah of course it is not
that as in in comparison to functional
but they actually demand performance now
uh while development
it's probably because a lot of
e-commerce website needed right uh if
you don't have performance you're not
going to rank better if you're not going
to rank better you can't have there's a
ins there's a huge drop the moment you
go from rank 1 to rank two let alone the
second page right
and uh
competitors we have a lot of competitive
support
so if you don't do that others will do
they will get that Insight they'll gain
that customer
money
yeah it's a lot and uh what I've seen
and I I agree with Honeys that things
have been changing over time because at
one mg the culture of performance is
deeply ingrained now it wasn't there
five years ago but today uh from product
to QA uh everything that goes through
the pipeline performance is something
that we look at because uh We've sort of
set a benchmark for ourselves of where
is it that we want to be and uh like uh
Hanuman and vilva said right that all of
these Progressive enhancements and
optimistic UI that we built they are all
contextual to an extent and who builds
this context the people who are going to
Define that product is going to do that
uh so it's also important and imperative
that uh the engineers and the product
work a lot closely the design team also
works a lot closely and if your
organization allows you to do it or if
you can influence your organization to
do it there are huge strides that can be
made in performance by ingraining it
through all these steps so uh like for
example we made a very conscious call
about
doing a design study where we can look
at different fonts that are available on
device and render something that is
closest to the font that we use for the
company right so we don't load our own
font in the first code and because we
don't do we we made that deliberate
choice we can scope we can skip the
entire critical path of fonts being
rendered on the page because the the
website can just pull out the font on
device for every OS we picked one font
and it can just render that quickly and
the moment you do any interaction on the
page or you move to the next page it
renders with the new font that has been
fetched in the background
so that that like cleans up your first
contentful print very quickly and you
would want people to see it faster
and maybe sometimes the design team
would not want to make a compromise on
that and that's also fine but it's
important for all of them to be in Loop
for all of them to have a buy-in and
understand why is it that we are doing
this
two important things which swarov I
think management touched upon one is
very important I believe the inculcation
of performance as a culture at
organization and projects and team
if if that is there at individual Team
level or pod level and organizational
level that can put in the dent in terms
of making performance the primary driver
for development or business for that
matter and second one sort of I would be
very interested interesting to know from
a font perspective mentioned about using
different as in the system closest font
or the system fonts were you able to
take how are you able to take care of
out and fight right so flash of unstyle
text and those texts
as well yeah so because we basically we
went with font display optional right so
the browser completely bails out of re
attempting to re-render the font uh if
it has not been if it did not find the
font in the first hit right so it does
not have any blocking period uh it does
not have any swap period either right uh
so the best part is that and if it does
have a blocking career I think it's
extremely small it's like 50 Ms or
something uh probably the smallest that
there isn't from all the fund display
types uh so optional is something that
works out for us and
most of the interactions that happen on
our website again contextual right so
Excalibur does not have other pages that
people might move on to and it might not
be a great experience there but for 1mg
most experiences would be either moving
to search or clicking on a product
and that will take them to a next page
the moment they go to the next page it
will render the font that it now has
which is the correct font so the the
people most likely wouldn't really
realize what has happened and this only
happens on the first render right of for
anyone the moment they visited for the
first time the font is now cached in the
browser now every time they come back
it's going to keep using that font and
there is no difference here
so contextually that makes a lot of
sense for us I'm sure my dissentee
wouldn't approve it
I mean it's very hard I I I worked in a
place where I had to fight a lot to
remove horizontal scrolling on mobile
website so they say this is beautiful as
design yes but in terms of usability you
do a horizontal school it goes to
previous page it does people doesn't
stay on our page so
yeah I think how to suspend that right
like if you are trying to search for
something
within how many clicks you are able to
reach the product that you want to
search right like let's say you type in
something and if it takes 100 clicks for
you to go there even though you're
performing your website is loading in
like fraction of seconds the number of
clicks is actually downgrading the
usability and performance as perfect so
we also need to be cautious about how we
are building that user experience uh
plus performance in tandem so that we
get the right solution otherwise
whatever we are going to ship it works
it is just that it is going to work it
is not going to create that wow factor
in your users
allow you
and that happens with us as well because
uh when MJ ships one third of their app
in web views
and uh very few people come back to us
and say that you know your website like
uh is in the or the app isn't that great
uh but we are running everything inside
the webview and hardly people recognize
it uh at that point we it's it's a
strict uh uh order from the design team
that you can't do all of that uh font
playing around with the font on when
you're doing web views at that moment
please load the font as quickly as
possible uh so yeah I think again
contextual and making sure that you're
in sync with what your team wants and
what what is best for the user is going
to help out uh I would also want to
touch upon quickly on the caching
bitrate I am very scared of cash
extremely scared of caches right uh and
I'm so scared of cash that we don't cash
anything
yeah
and luckily I was very early on in this
discussion I added Headroom right that
having a good performance gives you
Headroom to play around with this is
something where we could leverage
Headroom we said that even if we don't
cache anything we are fast enough to
uh slow things where other other people
would be serving with cash so we're like
okay let's let's do it and let's figure
out cash
uh
and do it properly let's not do it uh
because we had to implement cache and
then we keep running around in circles
and trying to fix problems that come
with cash
but caching is definitely scattered to
us in fact uh was something that we are
looking forward to doing is actually
caching everything uh when web views are
loaded because the app has a lot of
memory and they can keep and persist it
uh so and the assets for that make sense
plus our boot up time would be a lot
faster because you're removing the
network completely there
uh but yes today we are still running
web views without cash uh but
I don't know if someone has really good
caching strategies I'd be happy to so
doing caching is easy but cash
invalidation is tricky right you have to
go through that event driven
architecture of Kafka and everything
coming into place with headless
architecture each system trying to
communicate with each other which cash
to invalidate when so it is tricky
also I think one of the most common
anti-patterns that I see is throwing in
cash from the Inception ideally you
should actually understand the amount of
data that you're going to cache and the
usage patterns before adding the caching
layer sometimes what people do is they
throw in cash right from GetGo and then
see that okay it is not actually giving
us the return on investment let's say if
the caching solution takes like a
hundred dollars right you might not be
actually getting uh the uses of hundred
dollars that you you are just paying the
money you could actually survive without
a cash probably by implementing
something in a in-memory store
like you have browser databases right
you could actually leverage those tools
as well
yeah
um I think just going back to that
there's a part where uh like how it pays
out with design and other things
I think in general our websites are
getting more and more modern so
um like the fastest website would be a
body hello world but you can't ship that
to everyone
um we have to we have different designs
and yeah like more fancy things now you
scroll and something happens
um or like if your design team comes up
with say a use case where they want to
put a video on the hero the first time
in page and it's a valid use case you
can you can discuss the trade-offs but
if it's a valid use case you have to put
that video then you have to figure out
some other way to optimize that maybe
show a thumbnail and then load the video
later but um we have to do uh you have
to do that like that's uh how you design
your skills or even when you talk about
analytics a lot of third-party analytics
ends up um adding a lot to Abundant and
it ends up like causing a lot of
performance issues uh we should
obviously discuss uh the trade-offs and
see if some analytics is used or not and
which other Organics are used that are
the important ones but um at the end of
the day you can't just go and remove all
the analytics you still need some
analytics for your application
so again you have to like go and figure
out how to solve that issue then you
can't um exactly just stop that use case
so yeah
yeah uh thank you all for your valuable
insights and contributions to today's
panel discussion on web performance uh
we appreciate the expertise and diverse
perspective shared by our Este
Independents we also want to express our
gratitude to all the attendees who
joined us today
I encourage the attendees to connect
with our panelists and continue the
conversation feel free to reach out to
us with any further questions or
insights you may have
uh let's continue to prioritize the
performance for enhanced user experience
thank you and have a great day everyone
wow that was an amazing panel discussion
I think very rarely have I come across
panel discussions which are so calm yet
impactful and today's panel discussion
was one great example of this with this
panel discussion we have now come to an
end of today's virtual Meetup but uh
this is not the end we will all see you
again on 2nd of June which when we're
having the in-person JS con India
conference so uh let's hope we meet you
all and a big thank you to all the
sponsors speakers and everyone who made
this possible today uh it's been a
pleasure hosting today's virtual Meetup
and hope to see you soon everyone
bye
[Music]
foreign